i think you're ready to go okay
um so uh as the
division three finance chair we
started this meeting at 9 30 and we went
into recess
till now so i'll go ahead
and read the checklist and i want to
apologize to any participants who got in
on ninth
at 9 30 expecting us to get started but
but hopefully you're in for a good show
at this point
um the checklist uh uh as chair
of division three of the house finance
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 is
extended
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming
several things a that
we are providing public access to the
meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video and or electronic means
we are utilizing zoom video webinar for
this remote meeting all members the
committee and the staff
state agencies with agenda items have
the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen to
the meeting on zoom
or phone following the directions and
links provided in the house
calendar that's house calendar eight
with the instructions
it's on the gen court website
b that we will be providing public
notice
of the necessary information for
accessing this meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information
for accessing the meeting elect
telephonically
instructions have been provided in house
calendar and earlier i said it was house
calendar
eight but it's actually been every
calendar since then to include
12 which is the most recent
c providing a mechanism for
public the public to alert us this
public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access if anyone has a problem
please email
l b a underscore fiscal f i
s c a l at l e g
dot state dot nh dot u s
d adjourning the meeting at the public
is unable to access the meeting in the
event that the public is not able to
access this meeting we will adjourn
and reschedule i i don't expect any
votes today but if we do take votes
they'll all be taken on an electronic
roll call
we'll start by taking a
roll call attendance and i would just
point out that
representative nordgren let me know that
she had
a reason good reason for being late this
morning so
so although she's not here with us now
she's uh
with us in spirit so uh mr clerk would
you
take the role representative earth
president and alone in my office
representative weiler i'm president
kingston alone in this room
representative bean president
and i'm in guildford and my wife
is wandering around here and there
representative wallner president
and i am in my home in concord and i'm
alone in my house
representative nordman is expected late
representative rogers
i'm present um in concord in my
apartment
representative edwards uh representative
uh edwards
i'm in my home office in auburn my
family's in the house but my door is
we have a quorum uh
thank you mr uh clerk um i you know
before we get started
i would like to thank uh representative
rogers
uh for um her interaction with the
committee
last week we were going over
one of the budgets and we were dealing
with uh rents i believe it isn't was in
the management area
and representative rogers remembered a
historical conversation that had been
had
uh on the rents in the rochester office
and uh i i was unaware of it i don't
know the committee's history
so i just wanted to thank her for
two reasons one for being willing to
uh open up and ask questions and and two
uh if a question or information is of a
historical note
that's particularly important to me
because i don't have uh your shared
history so
all right so uh i think
i want to do one more thing before
getting started
representative earth asked me last week
what numbers i was citing when i would
say things like
ah that line looks like it's up 32
percent
and um for for the committee members
uh if uh since you have this excel sheet
there are four columns on the right of
the excel sheet of the governor's budget
and basically i just did a really simple
indicator
it's not meant to be real math it's just
meant to be
a tool to highlight line items where
i took the fy actual and the fy adjusted
added them together and divided by two
to get kind of a base
from there i took the governor's
recommended budget for 22 and 23 added
them
together and divided by two to get a
projection
so then i took the projection minus the
base
just to get a delta and then i did a
percentage on that delta
and i know that there are at least five
things wrong with doing that
if this were real math but the only
reason i'm doing that
is to give me sort of a visual
flag on which line items seem to be
out of ordinary or worth further
explanation
so i hope that that is clear to everyone
that was curious where i was pulling
these numbers
um all right well um are there any
comments from the committee before we
get started i think our first person up
today
is from the division of program quality
and integrity but i want to check in
with everyone before we get started
um representative weiler you're
recognized
well thank thank you mr chairman i heard
a
comment and i put it in the minutes that
the
general fund was up 45 in
hhs now maybe mr ripple would know
was that one particular area or is it
the whole
in general funds if it is that's a shock
um well i don't believe the general
funds are up 45
compared to the 21 budget that number
might have come
from 20 actuals versus the 22 budget but
i'm not sure i'd have to take a look
thank you okay so so let's have a quick
conversation about that
um representative weiler did a really
great job as i was sort of surprised
at the thoroughness of the notes that he
took just because he you know he's so
busy
but um so he sent them to me i made
some very minor modifications i sent him
to representative erf
what's what's the standard way that we
go ahead
representative norgren thank you for
joining us
um so um what's the standard way
in which we circulate the minutes before
we
vote and and do we vote on those minutes
in order to make them official i
i kind of need a class about minute
management
do you want to do you want to say what
you think representative wallner or
representative norgren what do you guys
think
go ahead representative wall are you
recognized
um i don't think in the past we have
taken votes on
minutes but i i do believe in the last
and kathy can correct me if i'm wrong i
believe in the last session
um kathy was the clerk
on division three and she distributed
her minutes to
um all members and obviously they were
put on file with um
with the the work notes of the uh of the
division
but i don't think we ever actually voted
on them
okay so to paraphrase it sounds like
they're more working notes than they are
official minutes is that fair what i
would do
last time is um i would send out the
minutes
15 minutes i took them on my computer
and i would send them out
between 15 minutes and half an hour
after we ended our session
to all the members of the division and
um any corrections anybody have i'd make
and send them out the next day with the
corrections
um so everybody had them so they could
look at them that night to see
refresh their memory of what we went
over so they were working minutes um
i mean i i had a habit from law school
days i could do pretty much
transcriptional minutes
and they just went out um that i mean
ken seen my minutes before
and i would send them out that day so
that people had a working um
knowledge and memory of what went on
that day um
so they had it for the next day and they
were working minutes and i sent them to
so so i so thank you for that and i
noticed you didn't volunteer to be the
clerk this term but i'll put that aside
for now
no no it's it's it's very hard work to
be the clerk so
i used to um be blackmailed into being
the clerk in the past
so i i i i have nothing on you
apparently
finance committee we've never had a real
formal process it's whatever the clerk
and
the chair of the division can come up
with and
most of the time uh i would turn in
handwritten
minutes to uh janet she'd put him in the
file and she'll say
i'll type them out come a break in the
in the summer or fall
but they were rarely ever uh typed out
i'm trying to do that this time
kathy has led the way here but i i can't
do transcriptions like she can but
i try to get as much as i can in detail
especially answering to questions
because it'll come up later didn't
didn't we ask that question what was the
answer and a lot of times
we don't get an answer we'll try
so um so i think technically i'm gonna
consider the notes uh to be working
notes
and not official minutes and then we'll
put them into the committee record and
mr ripple if you find out
that that's the wrong category but you
know let me know
okay we'll just try to figure out the
process
all right are there any other questions
before we get started or comments
from anyone um
okay i think we're going to have the
division of program quality and
integrity up first
meredith telus i think is her
pronunciation and then
what we'll go ahead all the way through
the
slide deck and then we'll go into the
relevant
uh uh accounting documents so that we go
from top to bottom without interruption
and then we'll have
is later and i'm kind of hoping to to
finish
by about two two o'clock 205
there's a hearing at 2 15 that that i
i'd like to testify on so um so we'll
try to maintain a little pace
and i got some feedback that 20 minutes
wasn't enough for lunch last time
so so we'll go to 25 minutes this time
um but uh all right so so
mr ripple you if you want to uh bring
bring uh
miss tillis in and yeah i think
everybody's i think everybody's in
okay very good i'm going to go on mute
everyone should
kevin do you mind also just bringing
over beth kelly as well
sure thank you um and just a
request chair if you don't mind with the
uh
notes from the committee if you're
willing to provide them to me as well
representative rogers did last session
and that was very helpful
um to make sure that i was hitting all
the follow-up questions as well
uh i think that's a very fair request
and we'll honor it i think
that with this first set of minutes
we're just trying to
you know figure out what our process is
and it'll get smoother and quicker i
believe
i very much appreciate that thank you so
i'm going to go ahead and turn it right
over to meredith
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee i'm
meredith telus i'm the division director
for the division of program quality and
integrity
and i apologize um i was reached i was
in the middle of rejoining when i
i think you were saying something about
the slide deck can i bring it up and
share it
kevin is that do i just bring it up and
share it myself
do that now
i hope if i can get a thumbs up or
something thank you okay
um perfect so let me
oh sorry i want to do
i can do that um so as i said
my name is meredith telus i am the
division director for the division of
program quality and integrity and i'm
going to start just by looking at the
agenda with you folks let you know what
we're going to go over today
so first just an overview of the
division
and then we'll have a conversation about
the bureaus that make up the division
and each of those bureaus key functions
key partners the accomplishments key
challenges
financial summary information and then
last i have a discussion of the
department audits there had been a
question about
audits that the department has been
subjected to
and i have some information on that a
the division um is relatively
new we were technically created by
executive order
in 2019 to be responsible for
the items that you see listed here these
are actually bullet points from our
executive order
so outcomes performance measures and
accountability
strategic and operational planning data
reporting and analysis
business process analysis project
management and implementation internal
audit and enterprise risk management
that was in the spring of 2019 the
executive order was issued and over the
summer and fall of 2019
uh the department leadership really did
some consideration of what work
um is engaged here and what would make
sense for organization
of this division and so it was really in
late 2019 we were kind of fully
incorporated
and pulled together two existing bureaus
within the department
with the hopes of continuing each of
those bureau's current functions
as well as eventually being able to
offer kind of new functionality
within the department so the two bureaus
that really had a nexus
to the intended work of the division
were the bureau of program
quality and the bureau of program
integrity
and i've listed here their former names
we've just changed our name
relatively recently uh because you may
see them referenced this way
in the budget document itself it may
show up in the briefing book or other
documentation that you see
so i want you to be able to recognize
both versions
the bureau of quality assurance and
improvement is now the bureau of program
quality
and the prior bureau of improvement
integrity is now the bureau of program
integrity
the names are just simpler clearer
and and fit well with what these bureaus
actually do
i'll stop there for just a minute and
see yes with questions
okay so so administratively i'm i'm
trying not to
interrupt you in mid-sentence so i'll
wave at you if we've got a question to
ask you
that would be great okay so um so my
question on this
is that i'm aware that there are several
efforts
to take good executive orders and to
craft amendments to put them into bills
so that we can turn this into
legislation
so that i know that that's generally
occurring do you know
if anyone is specifically working on
formal legislation for your department
so that you have statutory authority
going forward
no i don't believe that's the case so
technically is it
true then that if the executive state of
emergency were to end tomorrow
and the executive order was to go away
your department would have no authority
to continue
it's not the case um thank goodness for
me
and for us it's not we weren't created
by one of the emergency orders we were
created by an executive order
so that will continue to stand because
this executive order was created prior
okay and executive orders stand
beyond a single governor as well
so this executive order would continue
in perpetuity unless it was
fully rescinded at some point
okay so so ms rounds uh
if if if you if you could uh help us
i'd like to see if we can figure out if
there's a legislator who's working on
legislation to shift this from being an
executive order to uh legislation
it just seems to me like for the
employees of this division
it would be a little unsettling not to
to have a
okay yes i can um pass that on to
john williams my not to my knowledge i
think as meredith stated there there is
not anything currently in legislation
planned for this representative waller
has a question so thank you for your
answer mr jones
go ahead representative thank you um
meredith as you go through your
presentation
can you um let us know if there are
areas of your division that
have um corresponding um
sections in house bill 2
or if you don't i think last week
someone said they hadn't seen house bill
2.
we have a draft but if there were things
that you requested
that you wanted in-house bill to
um and then we can we'll have a
check on whether they're there or not i
appreciate the question
uh thank you representative walner i
have not seen house bill 2 either
but i don't anticipate there are any
specific and karen maybe you can
chime in on this too i don't believe
there are any specific items related to
this division that would be in house
bill 2.
i don't believe so i don't think so yep
if even when i do see it if i think of
anything i will certainly let you know
okay there was one section that
particularly jumped out at me and maybe
i'm in
it's in the wrong i'm asking at the
wrong time
but um in section 38 of house bill of
the draft house bill
who knows of what section will be when
it's finalized but
um there is 10 million dollars for
um to follow up on a report
done by alvarez and
it's about certain um
agency operations resulting in greater
efficiencies and accountability
yeah i didn't know whether that would be
in your department if that's in your
area or not
thank you i yes i hear what you're
talking about um
that is really i believe across the
department karen i'm looking for you to
nod her shaker yes she's nodding
that is it it would tie with my division
but not my division alone
um so the follow-up to that report
is going to really land across the
division in multiple
areas okay so maybe maybe i can um
follow up with karen
or karen could follow up with us about
that report okay
absolutely i think that language yeah
could could be um
discussed independently put it that way
there you go so since we're going to be
breaking brush
on the on the spreadsheet later uh miss
rounds if you could uh
draw our attention to the line items
that
would address representative wallner's
yeah that um spread out over multiple
requirements at this point
we could talk yes we can talk about that
later yes
thank you thank you for taking all those
questions
thank you and thank you representative i
i appreciate the idea of giving it
more continuity by putting it in
legislation that
that would be welcome um i do want to
point out what you see
here for the our general
responsibilities the things listed here
as far as
identifying outcomes and performance
measures and accountabilities and
strategic planning
and auditing and risk management
those are all important functions and i
don't want anyone to think that the
department
wasn't engaged in those functions prior
to the establishment of this division
of course every program area across the
division is engaged in this kind of work
in one way or another
but i think the establishment of the
division was really a recognition
that it's not necessarily their area of
expertise
each of the program areas are experts in
their program areas so their populations
their provider networks
national best practices there's a lot of
things that they're engaged in at the
same time that they're trying to do this
kind of work
and so the establishment of the division
was a way of kind of trying to
centralize expertise
in these areas so that we can partner
with the program areas and they can get
on with their day jobs
while being able to rely on us to to
build some of these skills and practices
and help them better achieve their goals
so i just wanted to to point that out to
everyone
and here is a slide with our contact
information so myself
division director and then tasha
blanchard
is our bureau administrator for the
bureau of program integrity and susan
brown is our bureau administrator for
the bureau of program quality
and they're both on this call today for
when you ask me difficult
questions you can call any of us
at any time and we'll work together to
get you an answer for any questions you
this is our mission statement and i'm
not going to read it to you but i will i
will pause and give you a minute to read
it
and you will note we don't have a vision
statement
i'm sorry i'm a little slow uh my
question here is under financial
integrity
um if if if for example and i'm sure
it's not happening
but if for example we were receiving
federal money
for program x and we weren't precisely
within the scope of x
would this office be the key accountable
office for just
figuring that out and reporting it there
are a couple different areas so
every program area and all the finance
managers are also responsible for
ensuring compliance of course
but yes we do have the internal audit
function so
if we are doing a review of that area
we'd be uncovering that kind of thing
we also have um
a grants administrator who sits within
our contracts unit
and she is
primarily working on establishing the
internal controls that will help each of
the program areas and each of the
finance managers make sure they're
in compliance on a regular basis so
that's
one we also have the inter we have the
internal audit function in our division
and another
um key function that we perform is we
really facilitate audits when auditors
come to us which is why i'm doing a
presentation on department-wide audits
at the end of the
at the end of this um so
for example our single audit of federal
funds is really our biggest
um biggest audit there but it's also the
case that um
a federal agency or the oig could come
in and audit a specific
area when there are findings there our
division would
work with the program area and the
finance managers to say all right here
are your findings
what are you going to do to fix it so
we're really pushing on the corrective
action plans to make sure those things
get remediated
timely so just as a thought
i think lba does what they consider to
be an external audit
and if you're also doing audits but
they're internal in nature
having that in your mission statement
may help
yep that's a great point that's a great
point i appreciate that thank you
representative because we are
this year i hope to finalize our mission
statement
also develop a vision statement and then
create some kind of
key performance measures and goals for
our own division
so i'll start with the bureau of program
integrity
when you think program integrity you can
think largely financial
integrity and fiscal integrity these are
really the key controls related to cost
containment and reductions in
overpayments so you'll see there's six
units listed here and i'll go over their
functions in detail but just just
generally to know
they're really looking at accountability
and integrity as related to finance
so the first two areas are
exclusively related to medicaid and
you'll notice as i go through and i
think this this makes sense to you
because it's it's true of most of
um ocom um we don't
have you know key populations or
beneficiaries the way a lot of the
programs that you'll be talking to in
the coming weeks we're really
serving either another division within
the department
or program area within the department or
one of our federal partners
so in this case these two units
are serving medicaid so that we're in
compliance with some
cms regulations and the first is the
medicaid program integrity unit
so this unit yes has basically the same
name as the bureau but that's because
federally they're referred to as program
integrity so it's the same name
medicaid program integrity is
focused on providers medicaid providers
so they're they're responsible for um
prevention detection and recovery of
fraud waste and abuse
for medicaid providers most of what we
find
is waste or abuse i don't want anyone to
think there's rampant fraud
but we do a lot of provider education
and we do that
in partnership with the individual
program areas so let's say
it's like a dental provider we would
work with dr finney
in the division of medicaid services to
educate that provider it's a lot of
provider education maybe sloppy billing
maybe sloppy documentation
and if it's something we see
continuously we'll talk about doing
broader provider trainings for that
provider type maybe something changed in
administrative rules and they didn't
catch it
so we do a lot of that um
but we do occasionally find instances of
suspected fraud and where there's a
credible allegation of fraud we would
then make a referral
to the medicaid fraud control unit at
the doj
affectionately called mafuku and that
happens
on a regular basis we make referrals to
mafuku so
there might have been a you might have
seen a press release um last week or the
week before
i think um two main
individuals were arrested um
based on an investigation that we had
started and referred over
and it was for home health i think we
found um
instances of billing where the where the
individual the client was not at home
so they're innocent until proven guilty
but still um that's just an example of
the
kind of work being done uh
representative edwards
so specified doj is the federal or the
state
that's state level doj thank you
yeah and i'm just going to say i can
actually only see a few
faces so if other people have questions
um they may need to just speak out the
way it works
they're supposed to ask me and then i
ask you okay
thank you i can see you that's all that
um so that is uh medicaid programming
oh they are also responsible for
provider enrollment
so they have to do the screenings of all
of our medicaid providers
upon initial enrollment and then upon
revalidation which is done every five
years
to make sure they're they're not on any
blacklists and they have the proper
credentials
our third-party liability unit as i'm
sure you're all aware
medicaid is the payer of last resort uh
which means that anybody who has
medicare
or any third-party insurance we need to
make sure that insurance is paying first
and then medicaid pays after so that
means we have to have proper edits up in
our system
so that we can um reject claims that
should be or deny claims that should be
covered by another insurance first
and then um and then if for some reason
we didn't know about the other insurance
and find out later then we have to go
back and and properly bill them or build
a provider and make sure that medicaid
recoups the dollars
so um this these are both areas
medicaid program integrity and
third-party liability where the work has
really shifted a lot in the last four or
five years and i have a slide that's
gonna
kind of show a chart where you'll be
able to see that
because our population has migrated
out of fee for service where we are
doing the work ourselves we're doing the
the um review of claims for program
integrity and we're doing the
review of other insurances for
third-party liability
we're now in a position where we need to
do a lot of oversight of our managed
care organizations
so that's really shifted the focus of
how the staff are engaged
and we had to develop a lot of reporting
structures to get the information out of
the mcos and we have to liaise with the
mcos
to make sure they're doing this work to
our standards
and simultaneously we're still actually
doing the work for those that remain in
the fee for service
population and of course for long-term
supports and services that's all
in the fee-for-service population
any questions on these slides
okay
so then we have two units that are
largely focused on medicaid
and and food nutrition services a food
stamp
um the quality assurance unit and
special investigations unit
so quality assurance does
audits of food stamp eligibility and
this is a really kind of regimented
formulaic process because because it's
all um
very clearly spelled out in fns
regulations
we have to develop a sample size every
month
and then audit all of the food stamp
eligibility for
appropriate um income levels and food
stamp issuances
and we also look at people who were
denied food stamps or terminated
and then we developed reporting that
goes to the feds
but we also have a feedback loop back to
the bureau family assistance that
actually does the eligibility
determinations and we have
a pretty robust conversation with them
um that's actually been been um
i would say developed a lot more in the
last year or two under myself and chris
santaniello we've really partnered and
and the group has done
an amazing job they've split into work
groups to make sure that we're really
getting to the root cause
of any errors in eligibility
determination so was it was it training
was it um uh something wrong with the
eligibility system new heights
or or documentation what is it that we
need to improve
in order to prevent these errors from
occurring in the first place
and as you may know that um error rate
is then usually uh submitted to the feds
and then they would develop a national
error rate and compare
every state to those errors that process
has been suspended
um for some time and we actually just
got word this morning i think it's going
to continue to be suspended through 2020
fiscal 2020 and 2021 but we are still
doing the reviews
even though the error rate development
is suspended we are still doing the
reviews and we are still
going to be working with bureau of
family assistance to
uh make those improvements and keep the
error rates down
our special investigation unit uh
investigates and prosecutes client fraud
so that can be in the areas of medicaid
tanf or food stamp benefits again
the fns regulations here are by far the
most rigorous
so um this unit i have a slide that i'm
actually going to show you because this
unit
experienced some pretty hefty turnover
it's a group of investigators and
they're charged with
uh reviewing any referrals or
allegations of fraud for beneficiaries
for
assistance um we would do an
investigation
and then um and then recoup overpayments
or
uh you know establish a claim and just
recruit the overpayment or if there's an
instance of fraud
we actually work with the county
attorneys to do prosecutions for those
so in the last 24 to 36 months there's
just been some
some very high turnover here that's
impacted the work but
um we do have a we have a plan
everybody's very well trained now we're
hiring a bureau of net invest
uh a bureau administrator and um
and have a have a good plan to bring
[Music]
there we go so this is what i wanted to
display related to our recovery of
overpayments and what you
see here in the tpl recovery is this is
the blue line you see it going down
but the reason it's going down is
because where our managed care
organizations are now responsible for
doing those recoveries
they are keeping the money and on our
side
we are reducing the amount that we pay
the managed care organizations in our
our pmpm our per member per month
amounts
so i just wanted to display this change
because while we're trying to
ensure that we're um maximizing
our our cost avoidance and cost
recoveries for third-party liability
that's that's um data metrics that we've
had to develop with the mcos to ensure
that we're
seeing it in their data and then we can
incorporate it into our pmpm on that
side
um fraud waste and abuse recoveries you
see here that's for both beneficiary and
provider overpayments so that's both
medicaid
program integrity and the special
investigations unit
on both sides so i have a question for
you here
yes so as i'm just looking at your
organization from a cost benefit
analysis this is
obviously a benefit um would you would
you just summarize
um the a number for say fy2020
on the amount of the recoveries
that actually save general funds money
um for the taxpayer okay are you able to
do that
i don't want to put you on the spot well
no i just want to make sure i understand
the question so when you say the actual
recoveries
um these are these are total funds
so this would be 50 general funds
approximately
okay so i'm just looking at you and from
also from a very narrow perspective
we're spending money on state employees
and rent and
all that and so this is this is your
profit
okay you're you you're bringing us back
this money right
you know our cost is you our
profit is x and i'm wondering what x is
so you're looking for kind of a net
number
well first just a recovery number it
sounds like you just said 60
of the this delta 50 50
so 50 of what you see
here for total fraud waste and abuse
recoveries
would be uh general funds approximately
fifty percent
i'm looking tasha can you not if that's
about
yeah that's about right yep fifty
percent what number would you put on
that
just for any year for
any year generally like not just 2020 i
mean
any of them just grab a year i'm just
looking for a
ballpark annual it would approximately
be the same i mean as you can see here
from 2017 18 19 and 20.
is that 500 million what what is the
number yep
yep about 500 million oh sorry 500
000 of general funds
perfect that's exactly what i was
and and i do know you have other
benefits this is just
one i'm not i don't i don't want to say
that
this is the thing that's carrying your
whole operation but this is
this pertains to two units in particular
not
the entire division um so two units are
really doing this work
and i will say what we don't see here
is um the
recoveries that the mco
is doing and then that is being
reflected
in their data so that we can then pay
them
a lower amount so this is just the
recoveries related to our fee for
service
population and it doesn't really include
the work that we're doing
to partner with the mcos and say hey
you're doing this related to fraud waste
and abuse but we really need you to be
focused on this thing over here
there's a lot of kind of management and
oversight of the work that they are
doing
to make sure they're meeting our
meredith can i um just add to that
quickly this is also one of the
few areas that are not restricted funds
that these funds actually flow
through to the general fund they're
unrestricted revenues that are
that ways and means considers as part of
so this is a slide showing our
beneficiary case reviews
and this is not my favorite information
but i i think it's really important to
show the committee
because we are very very much a human
capital-based
organization i mean across the
department but certainly in this
division as well
and this unit experienced huge turnover
we lost
i think seven individuals first the
administrator
and then another another maybe seven
individuals and they were all replaced
except save one
save one person so you can see how the
number of um
fraud cases established went down front
end detection
cases went down this was all in the last
like 24 to 36 months
the the good news is we have a plan
to correct this and we have staff that
are very well trained up now
and a plan to kind of bring down our
backlog but i just wanted to
to show folks how important it is
that we can recruit and retain really uh
highly skilled individuals
there could have been let's let's keep
so couple units uh for financial
compliance unit and our internal audit
these really serve a department-wide
population
so the financial compliance unit uh has
one sort of key function related to
medicaid and that is we
audit uh nursing home cost reports
medicaid cost reports
to ensure that all the costs in there
are allowable and then we pass that on
to the rate setting unit in medicaid
finance for the purposes of setting
setting rates for nursing homes and then
another
major component of the financial
compliance unit is that they
assist in all of our sub-recipient
monitoring so this is an area that
if anyone has perused the single audit
you'll see that we had findings on this
other state agencies have findings on
this
agencies across the nation have findings
on this
subrecipient monitoring is really an
area that's been beefed up
by the auditor's reviews in the last
decade or so
and we have in the last two to three
years really developed a robust system
to manage our sub recipient monitoring
so we now have uh protocols
that make us look at all of our
sub-recipients
based on risk so we're looking at and
when i say sub-recipient
the the difference between a
sub-recipient and any other
contractor that we retain is that a
contractor
we may be spending federal funds on it
but they're providing a service
to us to the department and so we know
if that service is provided well or not
a recipient is a little bit different we
are giving someone money so that they
can go
perform a bunch of services in the
community for our beneficiaries
they're not performing it for us so we
don't know how well they did it and
hence the monitoring becomes
really critical both financial
monitoring did they use
our money the way they were supposed to
use it and the programmatic monitoring
did they
do what they're supposed to be doing in
the terms of the of the
notice of award from the federal grant
so that process has um has really been
developed more and this unit in
particular financial compliance unit
works directly with the program areas
and the finance managers and the
individual program areas
on the financial side of that so to make
sure that we do expenditure testing
where necessary we actually audit where
necessary we sample timesheets where
necessary
to make sure that the spend matches what
they claimed for
another another thing the financial
compliance unit is doing
is um we have centralized our response
to the single audit in particular but
they also work with program areas on any
federal audit as i was saying in
response to your question at the
beginning
representative edwards um when we get an
audit from the oig for example which we
we are going through right now related
to substance use disorder
um medicaid payments
um they ask tons of questions they need
a lot of documentation
and we kind of act as a liaison between
the program area and the auditors
because we speak the auditor language so
when they're saying oh we need some kind
of documentation for this
sometimes the program areas don't know
exactly what it means or what will
satisfy them
and we sort of serve as an intermediary
to make sure those things get provided
and then you know in the case of the
single audit it's it's similar every
year
so it's easier for us to go back to the
program areas and say here's what you
provided last year
you need to do something like this is
what the auditors are looking for
um and the other key function that
financial compliance unit has been doing
is following up on the corrective action
plans
for each of these audits so historically
our
single audit was managed within finance
which is fine because the finance
managers know all the answers
um but the problem is when it comes to
the corrective action plan they also
have
day jobs that they're trying to manage
and be very responsive to the needs of
of the program areas and department
leadership and house division three when
they have questions that need responding
to within 24 hours
so we moved the responsibility for
managing the corrective action plans
into the financial compliance unit
and in doing that we managed to bring
down
the number of outstanding findings from
prior years
by by many i mean maybe a dozen a lot of
outstanding findings have been
now mitigated because we just kind of
put a spotlight on it
and concentrated on it until we could
get through to the end we've also
brought down the number of
overall findings um and i think that
that is is partly a function of being
able to just manage the documentation
and know what auditors are looking for
our internal audit function is
relatively new
um in the last couple of years and
so far has been really doing
what i'll call kind of cleanup and it's
just
establishing um a sense of department
internal controls
so for example um managed to
issue guidance templates information
about policies and procedures across the
department and what we expect the
department managers to be doing for
policies and procedures
this this particular function has also
been working on um
reporting requirements across the
department i think john williams might
have discussed that with you last week
uh and now is we are going to embark on
our first
internal audit for the department which
is very exciting um partly in response
to a new hampshire hospital
recent new hampshire hospital audit so
we'll be working with new hampshire
hospital to determine what
is best for them to do an internal audit
um another major function of this unit
is coordination of lba audits
and ensuring that the um this kind of
the same as what financial compliance
unit is doing for single audits
this unit is doing for all of our lba
audits
so there's an executive order i think
it's 20
20 1403 that requires us to do
corrective action plans and then post on
transparent new hampshire
follow-up to our audit findings every
six months
well the department had been a little
bit remiss in doing that a little bit ad
hoc somewhere on some weren't on so
this person ensured that all of those
were on transparent new hampshire
and worked with the individual program
areas on corrective actions
and since we started i think we brought
down the number of outstanding findings
from like 63
down to just nine outstanding findings
and we're working to get those nine
remediated
as soon as possible that doesn't count
our three very recent lba audits but
all the all the prior ones are completed
so we have a slide on key
accomplishments
i'm not going to go over every single
one of these
they're here for you to to read and look
at
but i will i will just highlight the
we worked to establish data
interfaces these are specifically
related to medicaid
to make sure that we are as up to date
as possible
on medicaid beneficiaries so to do that
we had to create um these data
interfaces with the department of
corrections
uh vital records and department of
defense
and and it's either a data interface or
it's a
a report that we receive and then we
take that information and we work very
closely with the bureau of family
assistance
to make sure that in as real time as
possible we're identifying what
beneficiaries are
or are not eligible for medicaid so
i know this sounds kind of simple and it
probably seems like something that
should be
totally automated but i can assure you
it is not
and i highlight it here because it's
linked to
on my next slide what you'll see is one
of our key challenges
if we don't have real time
data and access to real-time data in a
in a
for which we need a lot of backup data
sharing agreements
and all kinds of hipaa compliance things
in place
then we were really hindered in being
able to
do our jobs as quickly as possible
representative yes
edwards so so i'm aware that on the doit
strategic plan somewhere along there
they have an eligibility system
upgrade or maybe it's an entire
replacement
are are you aware of that initiative
are you providing requirements
customer requirements on what you need
from that eligibility system
i'm not aware of that particular upgrade
where we can we do work with the
eligibility system
management and say is this something we
can automate
we'd like to look at automating this
type of thing there's some that we can
and some that we can't but
i'm just focused on the new system for a
moment so
are you are you using uh the existing
system of the last decade or are you
using a relatively new eligibility
system
we it's the one system is new heights
is the the eligibility system for new
hampshire that's the the only system
okay you may want to make a note to
yourself to just dig into
the strategic plan around replacing that
eligibility system because it sounds to
me like
you have a lot of experience in these
feeder reports
figure out what kind of cross checks we
need to be doing
and in this new system that really ought
to be
bought and configured to service you
if they're yes i very much appreciate
the feedback if there's a new
eligibility system in the works we would
definitely want to be able to
um have a lot of communication around
that
in this area and in the other work that
we're doing
um related to third third-party
liability and other things so
so thank you for the heads-up sure thank
you
key challenges so as i said data access
is really um
something we think about and talk about
and breathe
every day we need information to be
successful in our investigation work and
that means
access to data from different agencies
from municipalities from the counties
from federal databases
we need to be able to assimilate that
information
and compare it up against each other in
order to detect fraud it's the only way
we can do the work
uh technology so
software and contracts for for
technology necessary to
to do fraud detection and deterrence um
this is an area
we don't we don't have a budget ask
particularly to do any technology
enhancements but we did just
um get responses to a request for
information
for a data analytics fraud detection
system and i think we got 25 responses
so we are in the process of sorting
through those and trying to get a sense
of what it would look like and what the
cost would be
but that's that's sort of an in-progress
uh
item right now and recruitment
as i noted before it's it's um
really imperative that we find
highly skilled staff and managers and we
do have a pretty significant vacancy
rate in the bureau of program integrity
right now
but um with the recent executive order
lifting hiring freeze we have
so that is the bureau of program
integrity oh you'll see the old name up
here because this was
prepared by finance so it says bureau of
improvement and integrity staffing but
it's
your program integrity and this is our
accounting unit
79 35 64 positions
this is our budget comparison chart
you'll see we're now at about 50 50
so does it help receiving federal funds
by having an identified
structure to do these programs
yes the so the federal funds we receive
are because the work that we're doing is
actually federally required
for the program areas so um
medicaid for example we're required to
do third party liability
we're required to do program integrity
so they
fund our units the same way they fund
those i mean very very similar funding
i'll say it's about 50 50.
and this is just information about where
you can find the unit
in the budget book and on the budget
in the in your budget briefing book and
the budget book itself
so chair this is where i would ask do
you so
there are two accounting units related
to meredith bureau this one and then
another one but she's about to go over
that second bureau now
do you want to wait to look at both
accounting units at the end of her
total presentation or do you want to
look at this one now and look at the
other one later
so she just finished a presentation if
there is
one set of accounts that address
or consistent with what she just did
let's do them now
it's top to bottom and then if there's a
second presentation we'll look at the
second set of accounts with that okay
so meredith if you want to stop sharing
i'll go ahead and share the
okay
can i ask a question about her last
comment before we go to the numbers
um you're recognized
you mentioned your head count was 64.
but the budget shows
69 or 68. is it is there a reason that
there's a discrepancy there
i'm not 100 sure um
position count from finance as well the
only thing i can think
is that one of them might have been
somewhat
um delayed and counting
a handful of positions i would have
expected it to be about six or seven
so it's not as many as i would have
thought but a handful of positions that
we had
in the last biennium doing the function
of parental reimbursement
so that was parental reimbursement to
dcyf and that
function was discontinued and so we no
longer have those positions
okay but they're budgeted for the next
biennium
i believe those are the numbers i
believe the positions exist but they're
not funded
so as i'm looking at well jumping ahead
i'll let you
representative edward representative
walder also has her hand raised
yeah i'm i'm i'm back about three or
four pages into the
yeah you're right i'm sorry i didn't see
you sooner i
i'm like playing with my spreadsheet too
so
please go ahead well it i think
maybe we've stumbled upon that answer
um before i got recognized but
so you meredith you have a 25
vacancy rate right now
out of the 64 positions
yeah right can you tell me what kinds of
people
who are you what kinds of positions are
these and how difficult
uh
some of the work that we do is very
trainable i mean all all work is
trainable to some degree right but
i think i think that um you know the
work
in um special investigations unit
for example we can train people to be
investigators i mean if they if they
sort of come with some skills and some
understanding
it helps if they have understanding of
program area but we can sort of train
them into that
but there are other other things like
um third party liability for example
where we need people
who can manage
a contract with a massive
managed care organization and hold
that managed care organization
accountable to all of our contract
requirements
and everything that we intend to see
them doing um
within the contract and understand what
it is that
we expect in third-party liability it's
it's a sophisticated skill set
and it is not someone needs to come with
a certain degree of skills that we
can't necessarily train them into um
so it really it really depends on the
function i guess unfortunately is my
answer
but um in some places it's
it's possible to you know post the
position and you you get applicants who
are gonna
fit that without a problem and in some
areas it's actually
it's actually more challenging
so i guess one question i would have and
i think this
this is a question i have throughout
sort of throughout the budget
and when we know that we're you know
we're 20 to 25 percent
um our our way our um
workforce is down 20 to 25 percent
our are our wages in this area i mean
you just talked about these are pretty
specialized people
are wages in this area competitive with
i assume it would be private
private industry that we would be
competing with
are we in within a competitive area
i don't um
i don't know because i don't know what
the wages
are in every instance in a competitive
private area so i i can't really answer
that
uh i can't confirm or deny
unfortunately representative walner but
i can say that
um in a couple instances we have just
now the hiring phrase
um freeze was lifted we posted a few
positions
and we received very few applicants
very few applicants um
so that's the you know it's it's
concerning to me
certainly and you have to think that
wages
no that that was a couple of pages back
but
anyway let's go forward and what what is
the number of the page that we're going
to now
in the budget on the spreadsheet
line item 13 750
we're on the um this teal highlight if
you will the first accounting unit that
meredith just reviewed was 79.35
which is on page 1168.
so so you were asking questions in the
area
i almost asked the question and that is
i i
i assume that of the people who have
left you said i think you said something
like seven people left
and you had almost a complete turnover
except for one person
are you doing what are you finding from
your exit interview process
what are they telling you about why
they're leaving
that's a great question i'm not sure i
can answer why the one person didn't
leave
tasha you may have some some insight
there
obviously i want to focus on the exit
interview
yep no um in the case of three of them
they retired so
they left government services service
the other um ones that left or a couple
that left
went for advancement in other areas
because
the investigative unit is very limited
in
its upward mobility it's from
investigator we try to put in some
layers
but it's investigator to a supervisor to
an administrator so there's not
as wide of an advancement as it would be
he's got us talked about
yes three retired and three needed uh
promotion
great um so accounting unit 7935
starts at the bottom of page 1168 and
goes on to page
question yes uh yes sir
why aren't we seeing these reductions
from the hiring freeze
in the adjusted authorized lines for
class
10. it doesn't the hiring freeze doesn't
reduce
the um the appropriation it
increases the lapse for the year
so the budget remains the same under a
hiring freeze there there hasn't been a
reduction in the
so it'll show up in the lapse but it
doesn't show up on the
adjusted authorized at this point
correct
thank you so to follow up on that does
that mean
that the fy 22 governor's recommendation
is budgeting part of the lapse since
it's significantly lower
than the fy21
because of those retirements um this is
one of those things we spoke to
last week when often when people retire
they're at the very top of the pay scale
and when a position is vacant
it is budgeted at the very bottom of the
pay scale so
other than a one position change
um and there may be some unfunded
positions in this area as well
that may be affecting that number but
probably the largest effect are those
were retirements and those now being
budgeted at the bottom of the pay scale
all right so you're still budgeting for
the same number of ftes you're just
assuming a different average
salary i believe so yes
okay
all right so this this this budget is
really all about the people there's not
a lot
of other money going on here
that's correct you see it's the
positions and benefits lines
why is no rent uh budgeted
beth where would the um
the cost for where these people sit be
budgeted is that
in the larger open budget
um yes thank you
um the copiers used to be in this line
and they're now paid for out of outcome
all right well does anyone have any
questions about these line items
because i i do not i just have one it
kind of applies to other places i think
i've seen this the fringe benefits it
looks like they're up
like i think 25 percent between this
planning and next
but i don't see a con a matching amount
going up in the in the salaries i'm just
wondering why would there be a
why would there be a difference there a
percentage difference
so the fringe benefits are set by
department of administrative services
um so that and they tell us what those
numbers have to be budgeted at
so we don't i'm not i can
get from you from department of
administrative services how they tell us
we have to calculate that if you'd like
oh so that's not like social security
that kind of stuff fringe benefit
insurance that sort of thing something
else
um right those types of things would be
included in class 60 benefits
i believe fringe benefits is something
else oh okay okay
that's i'm just curious what it is
that's all thanks i'll get that
okay if there's no other questions i'm
going to go ahead and stop sharing and
turn it back on i do have my i have
my hand up i hope go ahead sorry mr
representative
go ahead yeah so um i wondered
either meredith or um karen if you could
tell me
is this budget
what you requested of the governor
is this the agency are you meeting the
agency request here
and if you aren't what are the other
what's missing and um did you have
any um additional requests that you were
i don't believe there are any
prioritized needs
did we not have prioritized needs did we
unfund
any of your positions from the agency
phase to the governor's space
i don't believe so with the exception of
with the exception of the parental
reimbursement unit
karen there's six unfunded positions in
the governor's face
that's family yep and beth
i'm gonna have to work with you and i i
apologize to the committee
um it looks like our our what we have
for our pie charts
on slide 15 don't match what's in
the budget here and i'm i'm not sure why
um when i looked at them just now i
thought that's really high that's not my
budget it's not that high
but um i'm not sure what that
is so we'll get your new pie charts
we'll get new pie charts
yep they don't quite match
so back to representative
[Music]
one of the slides that you had been
providing last week was the
slide to just give us a quick overview
of what you do with more money what you
do with less
that wasn't in miss tulsa tell us
slide deck is is is that coming in the
next slide deck
it i apologize uh mr chair it's in
if on behalf of the division so i have
it later in the presentation
as opposed to for each of the bureaus
yeah now that that it's the the reason
for that question is to
anticipate representative walner and
others wanting to just know
um what a change in in these
budget requests would do to you so
yep and i can go over that by division
and if we need to split it up by bureau
i can do that too
all right i'll i'll defer to uh mr
ripple and
um and the minister hands on how to
thank you so much so
all right meredith back to you on the
second part of your presentation okay
and now we will be
okay this is where we left off i believe
discussing the bureau of program quality
so bureau of program
i just i want to have the spreadsheet up
at the same time could you go to your
last slide so i know which
fund we're going to be talking about
that was
um page 1168 looks like
accounting unit 79.35
we just finished that didn't we
oh i apologize um so and you want to
look at
program quality and you're talking about
dpq
and that is i'm going gonna have to go
to the end i apologize but i can find it
for you
getting a preview of all the slides
chair do you want to wait to look at the
other accounting unit until she presents
on the area
i do but i want to she's doing the
slides i
i want to be looking at the spreadsheet
it's accounting unit 66.37
and i can find the page for you the page
is 11.82
now we'll go backwards through the
slides
so bureau of program quality uh
has four individual units
and each of those is is
functions either one or a combination of
functions that are really
designed to assist the bureau
sorry the department the whole
department in meeting
its overall objective to improve the
design
and the quality and the effectiveness of
our services
so when you think of the bureau of
program quality
you can think um data
data there's a lot a lot of focus
on data and getting our hands on the
right data and using the data to tell
the story
of um how much did we provide for
services
how well did we provide it and was
anyone better off
so um really looking at program quality
by evaluating the data
and the data integrity first and then
conducting the data analysis to see what
the data is telling us
so i'll go into each of the four
functions kind of in more detail
starting with our data analytics and
reporting unit
so all of our units are important
but only data analytics and reporting
got two slides
because they are doing a lot of the
heavy lift lifting as far as data
management
and reporting so just to
to give you a sense we get data from a
host of places and in fact this unit
i'll go to the next slide for a second
if you can see at the bottom here data
systems oversight
this unit actually manages a handful of
data systems itself um but generally you
know we get data from a host of places
through our department billing systems
from national metrics from surveys and
audits that we do
ourselves and then we evaluate
that data for accuracy and have to make
sure there
aren't conflating factors and then
analyze the data for the program or we
help the program analyze the data
or we work with external vendors that
might have been retained
to do to do performance analysis for us
um so a couple of the key functions
you'll see here for example
are data analytics and reporting works
on
our behavioral health analytics so that
we can do monitoring and analysis of
some of the metrics that are required
for the state's mental health settlement
agreement
just to give you a flavor of some of the
ad hoc reporting that they do what
they're really famous for
at least around here is when people need
to know something
about their population about like
demographics or claims or
you know services maybe some kind of
ratio like what percentage of people
um got this service this way or
or um what's the trend in this area
you come to data analytics and reporting
so for example myself
on behalf of another program i needed to
know about
ob services so new hampshire is a very
rural state and that impacts how people
access
services so i worked with data analytics
and reporting to say how would i figure
out
where people are getting their prenatal
their labor and delivery and their
postnatal care and data analytics and
reporting is doing that
analysis for me and then figuring out
how to show it to me
in a way that is that is digestible
um another major function of this unit
is you'll see
at the top of the slide here are
medicaid quality monitoring
so this uh unit is managing our medicaid
quality information systems
publicly facing website you can
if you haven't yet i encourage you to
visit the website
and they are managing 7 000
individual data points i just found this
out last week it's
the incredible which get rolled into 200
individual measures and those are used
to measure the quality of our managed
care
organizations so
this one in particular you can see it's
just an example but this is emergency
department visits
that are potentially treatable in
primary care
and if you were to be on the website
with this one you could
click on this blue line
and it would break out into three
individual lines
showing you the track record of each of
our individual managed care
organizations
and this this this example in particular
i noticed just the other day if you look
at q2
of 2020 you can look at the difference
between q1 and q2 of 2020
you can see the impact of covid
happening right there
so that's i find that very interesting
i'm kind of a data geek
so you can see the the reduction in
emergency room visits
right there and then the next slide
i wanted to show you is another sort of
critical component of what
this is work that we're doing on the
development of um
an enterprise business intelligence
opioid crisis dashboard so you can see
draft written this is just
this is in practice it's in development
it's not out yet it's not publicly
facing but
um this is work that we are doing
to identify map metrics and this was
done
in conjunction with another one of our
our bureau units our substance misuse
planning and evaluation
unit to really identify
the measures that matter related to the
opioid crisis
and the work that this unit um
our data analytics and reporting is
engaged in it's sort of represented here
is they're working to standardize
department data and standardize
data presentation so step
one is really picking the right data
to tell a story and there's kind of a
science behind
that knowing what metrics matter and
what metrics
don't matter or are proxies are too far
away to really be important
so getting that data standardization
across all of our individual program
areas in the department
is really important so that people like
you can see it
and know uh what they're looking at is
relevant
and one of the one of the things we've
been discussing is is
moving towards certain frameworks of
telling stories so for example using
social determinants of health
um would be a way that if we can kind of
gear all of our data that direction
then we can start looking at outcomes
across our whole populations as opposed
to in
individual program areas
so the second piece um that this unit is
moving towards
is data visualization and that is
is its own very specialized science but
developing our skills and data data
visualization
is really really important as we move
towards
better use of dashboards to manage our
programs and
to provide to you guys policymakers um
to help make
policy decisions so so those are kind of
two
mr chair yeah so so i love visual
information i'm just curious about
where the personnel are coming from that
are sort of the visual information
experts on getting the data and
creating the graph or are they coming
from the is department are they
organic to this bureau so
this was a partnership between the
bureau of information systems
and our unit and i think the the
division of public health they were all
working together on this i'm not sure if
anyone was more responsible for data
visualization than any other
susan do you know better who was working
on that
so you're accurate meredith it was those
departments so
those other divisions it was public
health along with our
bis and data analytics and reporting and
then they also were working with a
contractor as well
i believe it was deloitte right thank
you yeah
but to get to the to the um
to your point mr chair the
data visualization skill set
is not one that we have um clearly
identified within the department
it's one that i would like to develop
within our division however so that
because we sort of um partner with all
of the areas
in in their data management i'd like to
also be able to offer the visualization
piece as well
but we don't we don't have anyone
clearly identified to do that at this
time
luckily we have a lot of smart people
who can do it without trying too hard
but like i said it's it's a science in
and of itself and it's a skill that can
be developed
right so that would just make me wonder
if it belongs in the is group or in your
group
but you'll figure that out yes and i
i don't um i think dave readers is
um call um
he is probably yes he's
okay writing me as we speak um but uh
yes we can certainly have that
i would um so
so far we're leveraging deloitte our our
external vendor as the data
visualization leads
yeah in the future i think it's a skill
we should be able to have internally as
well
i think it's very important skill and
and i would have this conversation with
dave but personally i think it belongs
more
in our bureau um i think that because
you know we're really doing the data
determination
uh he's agreeing he's agreeing he's just
texted he agrees
so i mean you know that's because it's
really managing the
systems and how the systems are speaking
to each other and we partner with them
on this we wouldn't do anything in a
vacuum
but um i do think i do think it's just
it's a highly scheduled a highly
specialized skill
to be able to create a dashboard that
people can see
and in real time use to manage things
and that kind of is linked closer to the
data
science than it is to the is science
so our medicaid quality program
so they are responsible for um
our medicaid quality strategy which is a
federal requirement
uh as cms requires that anyone who
engages in managed care
as a as a medicaid management strategy
we have to tell them in writing once
every three years
how we are going to measure the health
of our population that's
that's covered in managed care so the
measures that i was referring to before
this area
takes those then from our from our data
analytics and reporting
and works with the individual program
areas to identify genuine
issues so any trends or outliers that
aren't going in the right direction
and in addition to those 200 measures
they also review another 50 different
tables and reports
for the same thing they'll work with
program areas to highlight things where
they say this isn't going the way you
want it to
um the program area may determine
they're not satisfied
with the mcos performance and then that
would trigger a conversation with henry
littman our medicaid director
and probably a kind of a frank
conversation with
the managed care entity to get it
remedied
um this unit also manages our let me
just see if i have no okay
um also manages our external
quality review organization eqro
external quality review
organization which is also a cms
requirement that we have that
um and that vendor
manages the quality of our encounter
data which is like the
individual claims data that's coming in
from the mcos
um they help to do oversight of the
specific performance improvement plans
each of our mcos has to have a handful
of performance improvement projects that
they're working on every year
and this area is is the eqro is kind of
managing those in this area there's
oversight of that
and we've also identified 10
key um
areas of performance measures that we're
going to focus on with the mcos
this year i can't remember for updating
those annually
um susan the 10 performance indicators
we have that are related to
um access and timeliness and
and beneficiary experience are those
annually
updated no so it's part of the the
three-year
quality strategy okay okay so those are
every three years
so those ten indicators are things that
we've chosen to focus on are things like
um adolescent vaccinations
certain screenings for women um
adherence to antipsychotic medications
it's
ten very specific areas that new
hampshire chose to really
focus on and drill into uh yes chair
this question
so so i just want to understand when you
say uh
new hampshire has chosen these metrics
there are things like
organizations like ncqa promulgating
i think it's hedis h-e-d-i-s
i'm not sure are you are you really
leveraging
national standards programs for quality
as opposed to going on your own and
sort of creating your own metrics we do
utilize hedis measures for uh our
comparators and i i i can't remember
off the top of my head susan i might be
able to see this
um whether all 10 of these fall
into hedis metrics or not
um it's all but
one okay is either um part of hedis or
it's part of the core set the cms core
set of measures
and then and then what's the one outlier
right not specifically but why
is there an outlier is it because he
just didn't match
and so we had to make up our own metric
no so
it what we did is we looked at what the
lowest performing measures were
that could have the best impact on the
health of this population
and we also worked with the division of
medicaid services to tie these
into their their apms
so their alternative payment methods as
well as the withhold and incentive
program
uh representative weiler has a question
yes
thank you mr chair so much of this deals
with i.t
and normally when we look at a budget we
see uh
that they have um you know
a tie with the with i.t
and that they have have given them some
money from their budget and
and i look at things like going to
deloitte for
information that we may have in-house in
our own i.t
section i wonder how much you are
working with i.t
thank you so we work
very closely with bureau of information
systems
and much of our
data um is stored in a in a
variety of different systems really but
a lot of it is
medicaid related and so that would be
the mmis system
um and that would actually be in the
mmis sorry in the medicaid
budget in particular um
some of the other data that we're
getting
representative is actually subscriptions
to data sets so those
come into the department in the form of
certain reports we might be able to get
into someone's external data system and
then we have access to their
data but it's not necessarily a system
that we own but something that we can
access
thank you so yeah i'm not sure if that
answers your question but it's
it's uh there there aren't um
there are some systems that the
department
owns outright i think the phoenix system
falls into that category the width sys
which is one that we manage
um the wit system that we we
own or manage your lease in one way or
another um
but not not this
bureau in isolation it's work that we're
doing on behalf of other bureaus
give me one more thing the um
acronym you and the chairman were
talking was it
h-e-d-i-s
it's it stands for health care
effectiveness data and
information set okay it's in my list of
acronyms somewhere hopefully
thanks thank you representative
any other questions i was missing so to
follow up on representative weiler's
question a little deeper uh as i look at
at the
at the budget for uh qai
operations i don't see transfers to
is um and even how dependent you are i'm
just wondering
do they just budget completely
separately
from you and you rely on their services
in a team-oriented way where you each
pay your own freight or
or you uh how how is the
i i guess i can wait on the answer i'm
just
trying to figure out what the money flow
is to keep
an integrated team there in dhhs
meredith i can jump in there if you'd
like okay thanks um
so the bureau of information services
which you'll hear from after lunch today
which is headed by dave weeders he
oversees
the technology for the department in
coordination with the department of
information technology
so rather than budgeting
what we would call class 20 27 is the
transfer to doit i believe
rather than budgeting that in each of
the different areas of the department we
budgeted in one place
in the bureau of information services
budget so you will see that this
afternoon
okay thank you
resented walner has her hand up
i think that it's the same answer that
karen just gave it
for instance the deloitte the contract
with deloitte
um would be in information where would i
see that
so we do as meredith was mentioning have
a few pieces of technology
that are budgeted within the divisions
that manage them
so most of the deloitte contract is
actually budgeted within
the division of economic and housing
stability which you'll hear from
tomorrow
in the new heights system mmis is also
budgeted separately in the medicaid
budget
um so some of those larger systems are
accounted for separately
but are our transfers to doit are within
um the bis budget
so i just wanted to show everyone um
one of the products that's being made by
the medicaid quality
unit this is sort of a healthcare
scorecard of sorts to help
enrollees determine a managed care plan
and this is actually it's actually a
two-pager but you can just see here some
of the metrics
that you can reach from the from the url
up at the top
um and um mira health caritas is our
newest
mco so that's not reflected here but it
shows well sense compared to new
hampshire healthy families
so that people can kind of look at these
metrics compared to national medicaid
you can see
and help them determine their own
our unit of substance misuse planning
and evaluation
so this unit really
works with a number of different
partners and is engaged
to help identify the kind of metrics we
would use
for program evaluation and outcomes in
the subsphere
substance use disorder sphere so
those are partners like um the division
of public health
uh chief medical examiner chief chief
medical examiner's office
um our bureau of emergency services our
bureau of drug and alcohol services
the governor's commission so all kinds
of internal and external partners
and looking to identify the indicators
that tell us
you know how many services were provided
how
well was that done and is anyone better
off
so it's the kind of outcomes you would
probably think of in the sun sphere is
there a reduction in er visits
are people housed are they working are
families united
um are people employed
but those are those are kind of um you
might think of those in terms of end of
the spectrum like through treatment and
recovery
this unit is engaged in identifying um
indicators and performance metrics
through the through the whole spectrum
all the way into the prevention area so
even in like predictive analytics kind
of area
thinking about what are the sorts of
indicators that can tell us
um in advance what are the components
that sort of predispose someone for
being at higher risk of substance misuse
or abuse
so this unit is really you know like i
said partnering with a lot of areas they
worked on that
enterprise business intelligence
dashboard i was referencing earlier
sorry uh so represent walnut your hand
is up is that from a previous question
so so one of my general concerns the
last couple of terms
is it just seems to me like
there's this endless flow of money
that's going into
drug treatment and so i keep wondering
are we doing enough on the prevention
side
is this the is this the bureau with the
with the smart people thinking about
what's causing people
to begin their substance misuse and and
what we can do to interdict them before
they get started down this bad road
i can tell you from my recent
conversations with joe harding
who leads this unit yes he is absolutely
thinking about this
but i i think that susan i can see her
face i think she has something she'd
like to
chime in
so the the subject matter experts in
prevention come out of the bureau of
drug and alcohol services and you'll be
hearing from them
later on i believe it's this week but we
we partner with them in providing them
data to help understand prevalence
and consequence of substance misuse to
help them
identify regions areas gaps and services
to really target
prevention services upstream
yeah so this unit is is
trying to define the indicators and
identify the data that will
appropriately inform the policy on
effectiveness
of all of the practices for substance
misuse
i'm not saying anything thank you okay
and our health services assessment unit
so
they kind of kind of gonna split them
into two major functions
one is the first you see here sentinel
event reporting
they are responsible for intake
of sentinel event reports and then
reviewing those carefully to see whether
it does meet our definition of sentinel
event and then running the review
process
and then the other major function of the
health services assessment is doing
external quality reviews of our
providers
and you'll see here um the the provided
some of the providers listed
uh case management agencies on behalf of
the
bureau of elderly and adult services and
for the bureau of mental health services
quality service reviews for attend
mental health centers
and then also redesignation of our six
psychiatric inpatient facilities or or
drfs designated receiving facilities
so the health services assessment you
know it's not that
uh individual program areas aren't doing
reviews of their own
providers because they are and they do
but what distinguishes health services
assessment our
our group is really the rigor with which
we design
the reviews so we're creating tools it
might be a it might be a survey
it might be an interview template um
it's clinical records reviews that are
very rigorous in nature
and allow you to compare provider to
provider and compare providers across
time
that's kind of what distinguishes these
reviews they're they're pretty intense
and very well developed
yes mr chair so so if i wanted to know
how many nursing home beds we have in
new hampshire right now
and how many we think we're going to
need in 10 years
would this bureau of elderly and adult
services
be the responsible agency to answer that
question
yes they would and do they do active
10-year planning because when i talk to
the good folks at rockingham county
nursing home
they aren't looking at a 10-year plan
i've asked the former
director a couple of times we just spent
a bunch of money on renovating
places it's beautiful but he has no
projected
uh bed count requirement in the out year
so
so who how how much real planning is
taking place
so i will tell you we do have a
requirement um it's relatively recent we
have only submitted
one report so far for 10-year a 10-year
demographics um
report and i'm trying to think of the
exact populations it hits i believe it's
it's medicaid population
and then i think the dltss populations
which would be
our our waiver populations so dd
um cfi
and then also nursing homes i think
those i'm going to put it in those four
categories where um we were required to
submit
a report to the committee i believe
there's a
committee on um 10-year
demographics changes uh
i would have to look at it and i can get
you that report
unfortunately this was pre-covered so at
this point
it is a little bit outdated and it's a
bi
annual report so i think our next
submission would be this coming
fall well i'm happy to hear you're doing
it i'm just surprised that the
disconnect with the rockingham county
nursing home not knowing
so i don't want to believe it i just
i just i'm glad to hear that somebody's
thinking 10 years out
and it would be really great if the
people involved at the county level
knew what the what the statewide
thinking was
that no that's a a truly a great point
um it like i said it's a relatively new
process
something we're looking to develop and i
think that the uh
requirements of the legislation mandated
that we were going to do the review
in conjunction with um employment
security so in the first iteration we
were really just focused on figuring out
what data we were going to use and and
um because data
um employment security of course has
elmi so we were
trying to utilize their information but
looping in the counties
at that level uh for the nursing home
portion of the demographic projections
makes a lot of sense right
absolutely so i will just
note a email that came through
recently um into my inbox related to
health services assessment
um kind of summed up for me what this
bureau the bureau of program quality
does
pretty nicely they were working with i
think it was elderly and adult services
on this one in particular and
other involved services had a question
on uh something they were seeing
in their data and once we
uh health services assessment drilled in
they realized that the way the data was
measured
had changed to make it more reliable to
make it so that one person and another
person looking at the same thing were
gonna
they were taking out the judgment one
person another person were gonna kind of
have the same interpretation and be able
to record it the same way
and so they were able to go back to beas
and say hey you need to think about this
a different way um because drilling in
to understand those distinctions
is just so critical in knowing the story
that the data is trying to tell you
and i just share that with you folks
because i think it i think it sums up
a lot of what this entire bureau's
intended to do is make sure that the
data integrity is there
and then on top of that do the analysis
to
to figure out um what's the story behind
program evaluations
and and outcomes at a population health
level
so on this bureau um
for some reason i can't oh there we go
uh key accomplishments again i don't
want you to
let me let me just get a checkpoint with
you because we're getting close to
when folks are probably thinking about
lunch so
so the slide deck how much more time do
you think you need if you're not
interrupted
probably 10 minutes or i mean we're done
with this bureau
and then we can look at i'd say this
will take one minute to finish
um because you know the key
accomplishments and there are challenges
um you'll want to look at the
spreadsheet i can't tell you how long
that will take
it's it's pretty similar to the one you
saw before and that it's largely
um salaries human capital
and then um and then i i did want a
minute to go over department audits
and that might take five to ten minutes
there are accomplishments i don't want
to read them to you
i will note the middle one that you see
here
um we worked very closely with the
community mental health centers
improve their their work
on their performance improvement plans
for when we go in
and have findings related to the work in
the community mental health agreement
and we we started encouraging them and
sort of doing technical assistance on a
plan do study
act format for the way that they're
going to implement those changes
necessary for corrective action
and as a result of that we saw a nine
percent improvement
on the quality service review sport so
and for some reason oh there we go
key challenges this is similar to
what you saw before um one is
is i having strong infrastructure for
data collection
and analysis and so that means having
the
required agreements in place so that we
have access to the data that we need
and then ensuring that the various data
systems speak to each other
dave readers who's going to talk to you
after lunch is going to talk about this
a whole lot um but it's it's key in our
area it's key in all the program areas
but i'll just emphasize it as i did last
time for
fraud waste and abuse detection and
identifying our spend
and making sure our spend is is
appropriate
and accurate and we're accountable for
it in this area
it comes down to quality we can't assess
good quality unless we have the data to
do so
um highly skilled workforce i
you know talked about that quite a bit
is really needed for
for development of our quality
management and data analytics and
reporting
and i i think you know it's um this is
just
an area that requires a very skilled
workforce to do the work um
and then you know lastly i think is is
something a lot of program areas
struggle with there's just kind of
increased expectations of what we can
accomplish
um but not necessarily additional
resources so we don't
might not get the additional staff or
additional funding for new i.t systems
but everybody kind of wants more
so so as i as i get to know your
department over
time uh one of the things that i'll
i'll be wanting to fill in the blanks
around
are the kind of the um the so what
questions
you know if if you if you're producing
really great
quality information so what what what's
the
what's the connection point between
really great information you're
producing
to changes in dhhs or other
organizational behavior
so that we're buying data that's useful
and not just doing an academic study
you are speaking my language i i totally
appreciate the question because
that's what we're always really asking
in this division
we're working with program areas to say
to them
let's look at your data and ask the
question so what
you put all this money into these sets
of providers or these sets of services
where did it get us how well was that
program performed
how much better off is that population
in particular
how are you gonna know and then how do
you manage to that
how do you respond so now you've got
this set of data
what are you doing with it there's a lot
of data produced in this
department for the purpose of federal
reporting
so i'm making all this data and i
literally just give it to the feds
because they require it
but then what do i do have i managed to
it have i said so for example with um
with our
quality assurance group and this isn't
my favorite example because it's
federally required that we do quality
assurance
but um but we you know we do these
audits
of food stamp eligibility and then we
report
on those to the feds and and that's
that's meeting the requirement
but it doesn't do us any good unless we
turn around and partner with our bureau
of family assistance
and get to the root cause and say hey
your error rate is this
let's drill into individual topic areas
and improve that error rate
one by one and we can teach you how to
do it we can do a plan do study act
we can do all kinds of things to show is
this working to change is it moving the
needle
that's the question we always ask are
you moving the needle in the direction
you want to see it go
so so i but i fully appreciate it
applies to our
division as well are we moving the
needle so as we have these conversations
with program areas
are we having an impact on them to
actually manage
better i think we're
very much on the same page absolutely
yep
yes thank you very much um i would just
second everything that mira just said
what i mean on the page the previous
page
about the key challenges the i.t
challenge for this department is a
continuing saga
it's going on for years and
it really behooves the
state to bring everything up to date so
we can get the answers everyone wants
everything's outdated everything we just
hear this every time we have a budget
discussion
so could we go back to the others the
previous slide with the
with the areas of uh the one more i
think
okay so to me the conversation we just
had
uh uh emphasizes the the box on the left
but there's a a fourth missing box of
key challenges
i think and that is that you're a new a
relatively new organization
that's not really ingrained into the
management culture
so that you can help set up a
data-driven
management system that that performs and
can be measured
am i am i just making that up or am i
hearing you right
it's it's sort of it's sort of
a couple different i'm gonna i'm gonna
break it up a little bit one
is access to data is just
really critical um and that's not
always related to funding but sometimes
it is
and then the second piece is really that
data integration and data management
systems yes
i wouldn't say that's necessarily
because we are a new
division um we can use data management
systems that exist
already in the department and in the
state but it is
sometimes a matter of having funding for
more licenses
and and maybe sometimes it's a matter of
getting new
data systems but but sometimes it's a
matter of um
just being able to access what already
exists right
well i thought i had heard that maybe
there's a key challenge in having
the the management of the other
divisions of dhhs
responsive to a data-driven management
program uh yes i hear what you're saying
i would not say that's necessarily i.t
related sorry i'm just trying to
i'm just saying is that a fourth key
challenge
it doesn't matter we don't need let's
let's move on
okay did you have a question i'd like to
say i don't think it's a challenge
yet we are relatively new and i'd like
to think that they will be responsive as
we engage with them
so far we've been working pretty
intensely with the bureau of drug and
alcohol services in particular
and they are very responsive to our um
our partnership i'll put it that way
thank you
representative bean it looked like you
may have had a question i don't want to
is there another question no we're ready
for you to keep going
so at this point um do we want to
take a look at the budget page itself
please and that would be
budget book page 1182. karen i'll stop
sharing
so so as i look at this um ms rounds
uh the one that jumps out to me
is um you've got total salaries
if you add them all up it's it's like
2.3 million
and all the fringe benefits is about 1.2
million
so that looks to be about a 54 percent
of that for your salaries you've got
another 54
for fringe benefits and that just that
doesn't seem to me
like that percentage holds up across the
other
divisions and i'm curious if there's
just
if i'm doing bad math or if there's
something anomalous about
the way fringes are calculated here
i can get that information from you
again the fringe benefits are
we're told how we have to calculate
those so i i will get you that
information
okay but but 50 you know i'm used to
i'm used to seeing in the 30s a lot
you know but 54 just seems
outrageous like something's there could
be an error there or something i don't
know
okay does 54 sound about right is that
i i honestly don't know off the top of
my head there's so many other numbers i
memorize i don't
uh memorize the dash percentages all
right
so in this division and maybe it's true
in others i would just ask you to take a
look at the two lines on
on benefits and relative to all the
salaries and
because it just doesn't make sense
looking at it to me
we can provide you how das um requires
that to be calculated
right were there
i interrupted you before you could say
anything about these line items did you
want to
you want to tell us something it looks
all like it's very flat
line budgeting it's all no more people
a one percent change in the state budget
is there
is there something here that you you
want to highlight to us
i don't think so are there any questions
uh representative um just my
question that i had asked before were
there any prioritized
needs that were not not addressed here
and is this the um request that you
um gave to the governor's budget
director
i do not believe there were any
prioritized needs here um
and i do believe it is the request that
we gave to the governor
thank you could i ask one further
question yes ma'am
uh i must i might have missed it but
what is your vacancy rate in this in
in this unit i believe it's pretty low
susan do we have
one or two one
we currently have one position that's
vacant for the 28.
okay great thank you good news
are there any questions or other
questions
okay so where where are we at or do we
have another presentation or
does that wrap it up just just
department audits i have two slides on
department-wide audits
right
um am i sharing it or not this may be my
favorite two slides
okay didn't you i i completely
understand
you should um i am also
very interested in audits and auditing
which i got back to my powerpoint here
oh this and this sorry this was the
slide that you had
referenced and asked about if we had an
additional
five percent or a five percent reduction
uh what would we do with that so you can
see here at data systems enhancements um
you know once we have a chance to look
through those rfis
we would perhaps choose to engage in a
contract with a vendor for
um fraud um
data analytics specifically we would
probably expand our use of
salesforce systems because those are
really
helpful systems for managing
cases and instances of fraud or also
we would expand what we can do for all
areas of the department in terms of
quality and performance
measures i mean right now we're really
focused on
medicaid and then dltss and we do some
work with
with behavioral health and we do some
work with um the bureau
of drug and alcohol services but we're
limited in what we can do
not because those areas aren't
requesting
more help but because we we don't have
the staff and the time
to get into all those areas so i was
approached by um
chris santaniello this is quite some
time ago in uh
division of economic and housing
supports to help with a qa
process for her work and we we don't
have the staff for that kind of thing so
we would expand into many other program
areas of the department to meet their
needs as far as
quality and performance metrics if we
could
i think one of the key things that we're
interested in and i know department
leadership is interested in is enhanced
contract management
so part of what we're doing now is what
i talked about with sub-recipient
monitoring
but being able to build stronger systems
of contract management
right now what we do for program quality
as i showed you in health services
assessment is pretty limited in
scope so we have a few providers that we
do very intense reviews
on but we don't really have a mechanism
to help
all of the other program areas of the
department engage in
active contract management and we would
if we could
but that's not an area that we have
resources to focus on right now
and then what's kind of the so what
their
contract management well the ones that
are established and ongoing
are you are you concerned that there's
some potential fraud that there's what i
mean
what what what do you think would happen
if you had better
uh contract management for that
uncovered set
i think it's i think it is fraud on the
one side although we
are beefing up our ability to do
financial reviews
of providers on a risk basis so i'm
because we have that centralized
function
in our program integrity group but on
the program
side that's the side that i think
there's room for
improvement in that um our
programs are doing oversight of their
vendors but
not necessarily from a risk perspective
um and not necessarily in terms of
when you think about active contract
management you we can
use our contracts to
improve our population health if we've
got the right
metrics in there and we actually do
active oversight of them so we have to
we have to put a spotlight on it and say
to the providers hey
we've got 12 v providers out here right
and your median for this particular
metric is 12 percent
we want to see the whole the whole
median get to 15
for example well now if i know the
median is 12
i can call out two or three providers
who are way below that median and say
hey
you guys you're the problem you're the
reason that as a state
we're only hitting 12 on this metric
that's the kind of active contract
management i'm referring to and
our program areas are not really engaged
in that kind of contract management at
this point
i also just add to that that there this
is where there's a strong relationship
between the work that meredith does
and the work that my team does in
contracts and finance
um and i would just share from my
previous experience as an auditor
that uh you know 95 of the time when you
find an
issue it's a mistake or or a
misunderstanding
that that five percent is where you find
some fraud or some purposeful
um disregard but even sometimes
purposeful disregard isn't necessarily
fraud
it i i get a little nervous with the
word fraud because it
it's not always that a lot of times it's
thank you definitely yep and then
another um skill that we'd like to be
able to develop or something that we
would do more of
if we had the resources to do it is
in-house
strategic planning expertise so this is
something that's done across the
department sometimes in-house
uh sometimes with an external vendor we
do have
folks who are highly skilled at
facilitating these kinds of
conversations about
helping you develop your your mission
statement your
um key goals
and objectives and key performance
indicators but um
it's not necessarily all rolled into a
strategic planning
exercise and that's something i think we
would like to develop
because we've used external vendors
to varying degrees of success um i'm
sure folks on this
call have had the same experience just
in their lives
um sometimes in-house strategic planning
exercises
can be successful but you have to take a
lot of time
out of your normal day-to-day work in
order to engage in that kind of thing
and if you're trying to actually run the
process yourself it's that much harder
so i think being able to centralize that
function and have one
area that's really got the expertise
where we can partner with individual
program areas on their strategic plans
and development of dashboards
that would be it would be a long-term
benefit to everyone
is that redundant or integrated with
what the management office ought to be
doing we heard that brief last thursday
uh when you refer to the management
office
i'm i'm not sure who that would be the
you're um so so from the commissioner's
office presentations
last week not sure specifically which
one you're referring to
there was a budget a bunch of budget
line items that said management office
okay i'll have to take a look at that
so let's not pursue that and just say as
you're thinking about that
please don't be redundant look for
integration
believe me this division is constantly
looking for efficiencies
we're very lean oriented we would not
want to duplicate something someone else
is doing
um and that and that includes so for
example i was referring to
hr because they do they do have a
function like this that works with other
people and we would make sure we're not
you have your decrements you want to
talk about and the decrements
fewer reviews really i mean it just
comes down to less of what we're doing
and doing it with less rigor so we would
have to
decrease our sample sizes we'd have to
decrease the number of um
uh things selected for review maybe a
smaller distribution of things selected
or just um um
smaller uh samples within each area of
distribution
um definitely believe a likelihood of
increased
um audit findings and repeat audit
findings
and poor medicaid cost containment
generally
so so my question about that is that
there's this generally this
is burrito principle about the 80 20
rule
uh where you get 80 percent of the bang
for your buck out of 20
of the effort so so as you look at at
the reviews and uh where do you think we
are relative to the 80 20 rule
we're we're we're only doing five
percent or we're hitting the 20
that's going to give us an 80 return
so you're i mean i think it's getting a
little bit to what
karen is referring to right like we do a
series of reviews
and then we kind of say um not
all of this is fraud some of it is just
an issue that we need to deal with
elsewhere
is that kind of what you're asking you
for what your instinct is are we on the
80 20
cusp or are we way under or over
getting the 80 20 rule implemented in
your department
[Music]
what we are doing is
trying very hard to make to orient all
of our work
toward risk so i don't
really want to fall into an 80 20 where
only 20
of our work is producing 80 of the
benefit
we're trying to parse out the work so
that
we can say based on the risk level of
whatever it is that we're doing
we're going to focus we're going to
orient all of our work
that direction so that we're getting
more bang for our buck
so for example um i mean i think i
referenced this in terms of the contract
oversight we have a formal risk analysis
process where for both finance
and program we evaluate our contractors
when they submit an rfpos
and say you are high risk for finance
not for program but you are for finance
so we're going to enhance our oversight
of you on the financial side or
conversely
we're not worried about you financially
but we see risk as related to the
program area
so we're going to shift our resources
and pay attention to you in the program
area
so we i mean because we have limited
resources we don't want
everybody to just do everything
uniformly and say
well within 20 of this we're going to
get 80
of the work out of it we want to say out
of everything that we're doing
we're going to make sure that maybe 20
of it is focused on low to moderate risk
but 80
of it is focused on high risk because
that's where we need to be concerned
all right thank you i don't know if that
answers your question but it's sort of
the philosophy of the way we approach
all of our work
it's the start of a two-year
conversation i think yes
indeed so um are we ready for the audit
yeah
audits yes so we've got a few different
types of audits
i i saw that one of the requests was the
last 10 years of audits
i have that i can get it to you but it's
it's it's hundreds of audits and
literally thousands of findings
so i wanted to start with just a
description of what we have in terms of
audits what our audit life
looks like at the department and then we
can go into whatever
additional detail makes sense let's skip
this
because i see you got a list and we can
follow up this is great
just uh do you have a slide that gives
us a us
an idea of what you're doing for a
corrective actions program
for findings so for
recurring audits single audit finding
okay
these are kind of examples this isn't
comprehensive obviously but i'm trying
to give you a sense of what we do
and and what we're looking at in terms
of findings so the single audit we get
every year they're looking at
five to ten major programs across the
department and
in addition they'll do a handful of um
type b like lesser programs and
out of that we'll have
we've been reducing the number of
findings we get it used to be
over 20 sometimes close to 30 and and
now it's it's down maybe closer to a
dozen i mean it depends on the year
um but so one of the recent findings we
had was non-compliance with
maintenance of effort requirements in
our um
what's public health emergency program i
think and hospital
hospital emergency preparedness program
yes
go ahead sorry so so you're doing very
well
at answering the the what i'm i'm
actually
questioning about the how how do you
manage your corrective action program
how are you taking these audits putting
them into
some kind of a findings tracker how are
you managing the
delegation of responsibility i'm
i'm more because because the the what is
going to change over time but i'm really
curious about
the how so we have
three different areas of the department
that are responsive to audits
one is our internal auditor is managing
all of the lba audits
one is our financial compliance unit and
they're managing all of the federal
audits and then um our in our within our
bureau of information systems
our privacy officer is managing i.t
related audits so they're kind of
divvied up when we get
a new audit notice those three have a
conversation and say all right who's
lead on this particular item and then
they act as a liaison like what i was
describing before they would act as a
liaison between the program area
finance managers in that area or the i.t
the systems owners in that area
and the auditor and say all right what
does the auditor need for documentation
what's happening what are they looking
at
what does it look like they're gonna
find in this instance
and and manage the audit itself and then
the findings come in
and then that same person whoever it was
that was the lead is also responsible
for managing the corrective action plan
holistic top-down view of all the
outstanding corrective actions
and that and and that we do not
we do not so we are looking
yep we are looking to we are it's kind
of in development
um as we speak but that is a key area
that we are trying to
work on so just to tie you in i i have
asked mr
kane and mr smith from lba to reach out
to you to talk about
correction action uh plan formatting and
reporting
because it sounded to me earlier that
you you may have something
that you use so if they reach out to you
don't be surprised yep absolutely and we
can
certainly have that conversation um it's
it's having a holistic
single system is certainly a goal of
ours because we want to be able to have
at our fingertips
where is this finding where what is the
status of it in every instance
but it doesn't exist yet so far we're
having to manage
the individual audit areas manually
i i really appreciate your your honesty
and directness
because you know a lot of people don't
like to share things that aren't perfect
and i appreciate your honor
i think we're we're very much on the
same page you know i mean i i want to
see that improvement
and we have i think what's really
important is that a lot of what this
division does
a a share i say like 100 of what this
division does is
we put a spotlight on the areas that are
more like
um kind of administrative functions that
the program areas can't really spend all
of their time on
and when you put a spotlight on
something it changes necessarily
even though people don't even they're
not even planning on it changing just
because you keep
poking them on it and saying hey this
metric is still 12
hey this metric is still they can't even
help it they start focusing on it and
the next thing you know it starts to
change
and we do that in a lot of different
areas including on the
audit report so like i said even without
that system in place
we brought down outstanding findings
from 63 to 9
just by putting a spotlight on it and
and also i mean i think part of it is
um the oddities may not they just don't
always speak the language they don't
always
understand what the auditor is looking
for
as a as a remedy so us being able to say
no no they're not looking for the thing
you're doing they want to see
like a formalized risk management plan
or something like that
being able to speak the language we've
certainly managed to make improvements
but
we don't have the system you're
referring to so if i need to know
where if where findings are i have to go
to the individual audit manager and say
tell me where this is at and what are we
doing with it
thank you very much uh is there one more
slide
i think this is oh there is this is
specifically related to um information
security
type audits and findings
i don't like that pci i will
warn you right now this is not my area
of expertise um but we do liaise with
bis for their audit management and they
work with us on our audit management
because it's all
it's all intermingled all right okay
are there any questions anyone uh
representative walner what what what
what what should we be asking here
okay i'm sorry i'd have to look through
this slide for
for quite a while longer um
[Music]
so do you think this is something we
need to look back on in three months
after the
hard work of the budget is done to just
okay the question one question i would
have and i
i now i lost the slide again
meredith i guess one thing that would be
interesting
for me to know about um
[Music]
these audits and these findings is
are any of them causing us to lose
federal federal money
on this area i
can't answer that right now um dave
weeders
might be one moment let's see if i can
answer that question in real time
um why don't we take that offline right
right write that down and get back to us
on that
are any of these could so the answer is
they could cause us to lose
but they are not yet they're not at this
time
well yes thank you and well on the other
side
um the fact that maybe we're
finding out we should have gotten more
money
so both sides of the coin hopefully
we'll discover um that's
going to yeah
yeah um representative uh
weiler i did i just want to since i've
i've listened to you talk about
audits in fiscal committee i just wanted
to give you a chance to say something
since we've gone through it here oh i'm
delighted that
that something is happening central i
haven't seen the
effects of this division before on
helping these others with answering
the audits and i guess one of the first
ones is going to be the new hampshire
uh home or new hampshire hospital which
had a fairly fairly serious audit last
time so
i'll be looking forward to see what
happens and when i do see answers
this unit doesn't really get credited i
do read a lot of audits and now we've
decided this last meeting we want
monthly follow-ups to see what the
progress is because otherwise
we see a budget that uh we see an audit
that
is a follow-up on one from 10 years
before and the majority of the findings
are still outstanding
so yes there is a definite need to
do quicker follow-up and do more things
happening so
i'm looking forward to seeing what this
division can accomplish thank you
and just so you know representative we
have set
a task for ourselves to be responsive to
all the audit findings within 24 months
so that's what we're looking at right
now very good
so is there a are there budget line
items that go with this uh
this segment of the briefing or we've
already hit them i imagine no we've hit
them
okay all right so uh i'm getting ready
to call a recess for
for lunch uh but before we go does
anyone have any
have i missed you does everyone have
their questions answered
yes sir mr representative weiler uh do
we have another slide deck to download
i think we already have that i think you
received that
via email the other day and it's also on
our website
what am i looking for i don't remember
i think it's called ocomb information
the cover slide has david find it when
i can i can email it to you again too if
that's easier yeah i appreciate that
thank you all right so uh it's now
at 12 22. um why don't we
uh recess until one o'clock
uh does anyone feel like that's too
rushed
all right so um so with that um
we're recessed until one o'clock enjoy
your lunch
okay so so let me let me at just ask you
to summarize this box
where mmis is the second bullet of
of the of the following
systems are there those
are those all legacies or are those
relatively new implementations
and if if they're legacies
where do they stand on your replacement
schedule
that's kind of what i want to know about
those items certainly
so as as i earliest
earlier stated mr chair the mmis is our
first one on the five year strategy to
re-procure visual components
the new heights new hampshire easy
integrated eligibility system
is a system that's been around a while
but has been properly maintained
and there was no deferred maintenance on
that system so i would say it's actually
won many awards in our country for being
a very effective integrated eligibility
system
our plans to re-procure that begin in
not in the next biennium the options or
elderly adult care system
is one of our systems that is also at
risk
that we would be looking to reprocure a
solution
for it is a homegrown.net
application excuse me that
we would like to look at a commercial
off-the-shelf
solution for that could not only combine
with elderly adult care but
developmental services and other areas
within long-term supports and services
so we can have
a single cohesive case management
solution to provide those services
our nexus or child support system
has undergone gone a major overhaul this
biennium
where we did upgrade the system and did
some major releases so we were looking
to
replace that on on a reprocurement
roadmap of 2026 beginning that year
it would be a two to three year
re-procurement program
if if at the time the state determined
that it was
beneficial to replace the system or
look at potential enhanced major
enhancements at that time
the web information technology system
also known as wits which is our drug and
alcohol services system
is a legacy system that we outsource to
a vendor
that we don't have in our in our current
biennium operational or capital
submissions
to replace as it is meeting the
expectations
it's not exceeding the expectations but
we we needed to identify when we would
replace it our goal was to start
replacing that system in 2024-2025
and then our sacquis or child care
child welfare information system is a
legacy system that's been around for 27
years
we currently have a capital program
for this biennium as well as planned for
the next
two bienniums to replace that system
it has an intake assessment case
management and claims component
we are we are goal that looking at that
claims module
and seeing if we have a departmental
claims opportunity as opposed to having
multiple different claims systems within
the department
looking at us a centralized claims
solution starting in 2025 2025
2026 to implement
so that we can utilize that for our
long-term support services claims for
our fee for service claims and that that
division as well as our child welfare
information services claims and medicaid
claims
did that summarize for you mr chairman
thank you that was that was
excellent and i know that we're an
operations budget
group here um in in the future it may be
nice
just to have uh one of the roadmap
slides
so we see you know some long-term
capital planning just to
you know because i think i think it
affects your operational costs too
it certainly does that's that that that
was actually a question i was asking
um our chief financial
officer during the break is how do we
coordinate
the communication between capital and
operating
it because operations is very important
but capital
impacts the strategic planning and
directions
as well as impacts for future
operational costs
so representative weiler do you want to
feel that or
or should we take that offline
yeah probably offline i don't want to
work on it yet
all right thank you so so that's a great
question and i think
collectively the legislature owes you an
answer
i don't i don't know how we'll get it to
you but we'll keep track of it
that's a great question i appreciate
that mr chair
it appears that you have another
question
i represented oh oh there you go
representative irf
go ahead could you just clap now that
you've told us that
eight of the people we thought were in
your department actually over another
department
could you clarify where the either 22 or
18 positions
the 22 you currently have or the 18 you
will have are in your
department sure so
thank you for the question
representative erf and mr chair um
we have nine positions that are
supporting the project management office
in lean
and then we have nine positions that are
current currently supporting
hardware live hardware application
lifecycle management information
security
and data warehousing support as well as
strategic
strategic planning and design so those
nine people
are broken up into several different
program areas
we have two for information security one
for
application lifecycle and hardware
lifecycle management
we have two for data warehousing
and reporting that work hand in hand
with the other data teams
so that's up to five and then we have
the deputy director and myself
seven and then the i'm
getting ahead of myself here and then
two for information securities
nine so those positions are all filled
with people
they are not those are our total total
amounts
so of those we are 33 vacant in both
teams
so we are down three people in each area
and so we're
essentially operating in with multiple
hats
across all of the all of the department
so just the remainder of this slide here
this application life cycle management
program
is his goal to implement
and it did implement this year the grant
trace which is our
contact tracing patient monitoring and
case investigation
it leveraged a salesforce platform which
our goal is to leverage that platform
and the licensing associated with it
across our department
as much as possible where where and
where applicable
we also implemented and so that
grant trace is really focused on covid19
response
and how we could understand what was
happening when
when people were identified with cobin
and then be able to monitor them
and then do case investigation to
understand community transmission
the new hampshire connections solution
is our child care registry and licensing
program
which historically has been done in
excel spreadsheets and access databases
which were prone to
error and failure and so our goal is to
implement a system that could manage all
of our child care professionals and
their registries
in training and certifications in a
single platform
again that was implemented on the
salesforce platform
as part part of the coven 19 pandemic
response to
ensure timely certification registry and
licensing for those child care
organizations and then as i
spoke about earlier granite families
which is our comprehensive child
child welfare information system is the
replacement for the
this item above and application life
cycle management of saqquis
and it will be a six year plan to
replace we're expecting to go live in
the year five
with that system but incrementally
throughout where
we have our we're already beginning to
go live with parts of it
and so why would we do that the benefit
is we're able to implement
key components that are having what we
would call
trouble areas and we're implementing an
agile methodology which is allowing us
to
take ownership of components of the
system and utilize it
earlier than if we just waited until the
end of five years to start
this does two things for us it enhances
our services
sooner which basically improves our
productivity
but it also gives us more visibility to
what changes we need to do
to meet the end result in five years
and then the last one here is ombudsman
case management
and there's other ones as well i believe
meredith tillers referred to it briefly
we implemented a medicaid quality
assurance case management solution on
salesforce as well
and we were able to do that rather
rapidly based off of the federal funding
for integrated eligibility components
and we were able to leverage it with
acf funding as well
for granted families so these federal
partners have
really helped us with 90 10 match or 90
federal funds 10 general fund match to
acquire the licensing and implement the
systems
so the the last component here is
hardware lifecycle
management this is the maybe the rest of
it's boring too but this is the super
boring part but basically it comes down
to
we're replacing servers storage switches
computers um pretty much any technology
device that allows
our clients our users and so i when i
refer to clients i
my my customers are the employees of the
the department
on directly and then my further clients
are the citizens of new hampshire but
this is where we're replacing all that
hardware and software
we distributed a little over a thousand
computers this last year
and we plan and we have about a little
over 3 400
on devices or like laptops or desktops
throughout the organization that we try
to replace on a five-year cycle
this last year we implemented many more
than we normally would
as a result of the covid 19 pandemic
response
we had to implement computers for
temporary needs
with the national guard being activated
as well as large call center
implementations so we have a question
when you mention these granite things
here granite trees and granite families
are those kind of granite
pathways
that's a good question mr representative
irf and mr chair
um they're not part of grant pathways
what we try to do is working with uoit
i believe everything that like the big
enterprise type systems have a reserve
name for with granite in the name
okay and so the idea was when we
when we it's like grand families or the
legacy system used to be called bridges
so what we're trying to do is use the
granite families as a branding
to say this is a new hampshire family
system
and then when it came to granite trace a
new hampshire contact tracing solution
so not part of expanded medicaid that is
not part of expanded medicaid
thank you so much about the hardware
life cycle management
how many ftes do you think are invested
in that
state employees and and then i assume
that there's a fairly significant
contract support there
so depending on the the hardware itself
um mr chair it would be
so when it comes to distribution of
computers we have
several different teams from information
technology department
or do doit that are distributed across
these the estate locations so we have
some in our haze and drive some of
in our our brown building and some in
other buildings across our campus
and so i would identify as about nine
people from
duit that helped us distribute those
devices
and it included about another six
of our individuals within the department
to get that done
when it comes to the cloud hosting
solutions to reduce costs on the state
resources
we we leveraged a contract with deloitte
and it was funded fully funded by center
for disease control and prevention
funds to essentially
to implement a cloud hosting solution
for our public-facing
business intelligence reports and then
when it comes to
database hardware and
the associated like server storage and
networking equipment
it was a mix between byt professionals
as well as we also leveraged the funding
from center
center for disease control and
prevention to upgrade our hardware on
premise or on site in our data center
managed by department of information
technology
to enhance the performance as well as
include the storage necessary
to bring in all the different data
sources related to not only the
the cova 19 pandemic but the opioid
crisis as
was referred to earlier in meredith
those
presentation on the opioid crisis
dashboard
did that okay so well it does but it was
kind of i'm what i'm really trying to
get at here
is is this feels like an area that isn't
necessarily
um a value-added service
it's not part of dhhs core competency
and um and i'm just wondering if
um if there's any strategic thinking
going on
in this area to to rely more on
uh contract support so that the
the few uh professionals that we do have
with a 33 percent gap there
that we maybe can reallocate them to the
value add
business analyst kind of positions
and and we can take that offline because
that's a whole different discussion
i i just would like to know if doit and
dhhs
are thinking about redoing hardware
lifecycle management differently in the
future
we mr chair we certainly have had those
discussions in
in this this whole slide really is
operated
by one person we have a senior senior
i.t asset manager
that is responsible for the application
in the hardware lifecycle management
along with myself
and the deputy director so there really
wouldn't be too much reassigning
available and that person works hand in
hand with the duit professionals helping
to deploy the hardware
and and and the vendors deploying the
soft the applications
um but when it comes to strategies in
terms of like leasing equipment getting
a contractor to do deployments
and eliminating the the resources
on on the ground that are supporting
our our agency on a day-to-day basis we
certainly are having those discussions
with uoit on a regular
um i would say monthly basis to decide
how we move that forward
i would be looking to commissioner
goulet to see what his strategic
direction would be on that
pardon me so sorry for all the text
but some of our key accomplishments we
already sort of
addressed but in the enterprise business
intelligence platform
we were able to implement public-facing
covid 19 pandemic
response dashboards we have an opioid
crisis response dashboard that is ready
for the public but has not been
published yet
but we are planning to publish it soon
and then internally we were
we're continuing to evolve the master
client index which
right now as of today integrates several
of our different systems as i referred
to earlier the child support system
child welfare information system
elderly adult care medicaid and
integrated eligibility but our goal is
to expand that
and to include our behavioral health
system which is now landed
or is present in our data warehousing
environment but is not integrated at a
at a client level as well as
other public health and new hampshire
hospital systems as we go forward
we also were able to create that
scalable infrastructure for the the
dashboards that are being currently used
across
all divisions within the department in
that system
as a result of funding from grants was
able to be expanded for the next
year to two years and our goal is
through a capital request to continue to
fund
that security and awareness
in conjunction with the chief
information security officer doit
successfully implemented a
department-wide training and awareness
program this past january
and we're also streamlining contract
processes for security and privacy by
creating templates
that are have been vetted by multiple
vendors as well as
throughout our department doit and the
attorney general's office
to be compliant with our federal federal
and state policies
and legislation and
then we also in terms of data
data management we implemented data
classification policy
so that we could track what data is
allowed to be shared
shared at different levels and what kind
of governance needs to be addressed for
each one
this was critical for privacy management
for the state
to ensure that we can see what who has
access to what and when
and why so that whenever anyone asks us
why are we sharing this data this is how
we're sharing it and this is the laws
that allow us to share it
in one for example we managed to met
auditing requirements associated with
federal different
with several different audit auditing
agencies listed there
and then from interoperability and
integration perspective
we we deployed those departmental case
management systems
so that we could rapidly respond to the
needs
um had we not started that initiative on
this biennium at the beginning of this
biennium
currently we would not have been able to
meet the needs of contact tracing
child child care licensing and registry
quality assurance components as well as
ombudsman's office case management
processing
that was a key success for our
department to be
able to move those systems forward in
months as opposed to years
and sometimes weeks in some cases weeks
the grant trace solution was implemented
over a weekend it took us
four business days to get in when i say
four business days friday saturday
sunday and monday
and then we at the end of the calendar
year of 2020
we did implement the closed loop
referral system which is gold at
improving our care coordination between
our providers of our state
and then the final component here is
system stabilizations
so we're working on a strategic plans
across the board
we started with the medicaid enterprise
strategic plan
which is a five-year plan addressing all
the components of the medicaid
enterprise
as well as organizational information
services strategic plan which
is representative in the agency
information technology plan that
the commissioner of dyt publishes
and then we have a portfolio of our
projects which is we average about 120
active projects at any given time
and as a result of having a small staff
we usually complete anywhere from 20 to
i want to i want to step in here and
brag on you guys for a little bit
we went uh for most of the year
2000s with one strategic plan that never
got updated
and now it seems to me like you are with
doit
in a regular rhythm of doing strategic
planning and updating it
and that is a huge step forward i think
in our
in your profes in the professionalism of
the effort
and and the benefit that the state will
get out of that so
i just wanted to highlight that from
what i've seen
you guys are really doing a a great job
in the strategic planning area
thank you very much mr chair now i want
to come back to something though because
i said something good now i have to go
the other way
keep it balanced so i i see that
you've got security and awareness and
you got the
payment card industry listed there and
and i think we have an audit outstanding
where
we have some serious problems with our
pci standards
uh are we are you aware of that audit
and are we at the point where we need to
remove permissions
mr chair i i am aware of an audit
regarding the
payment card industry of our of our
state systems
we are peripherally involved as a as a
supporting agency with department of
administrative services which is the
lead agency i believe
on that audit i don't believe we need to
remove
access because we did implement a new
contract as a result of some of those
audit
issues and i believe we're going to be
able to address any
any concerns regarding the sharing of
credit card information
but i would i would leave the the
official answer
to commissioner arlinghaus um to address
it as needed if and i believe that's
where
the lead agency is on that but i can
follow up on you on that
for you if you if you would like uh
i would uh and i don't have direct
contact with commissioner arlingham
but having having pci problems is uh
you know concerns me just
go ahead it's a it's a concern for us as
so key challenges for the organization
again um the main main challenges here
are lack of interoperability between our
systems and integration we've made
headway on those
on those challenges but we need to
continue our efforts
the reason why is that not having
integration and interoperability between
systems
lends itself to duplication of effort
wasted time
on solutions they've already been
thought through
and strategically addressed and it
really takes resources away from their
comment their
their true intention of the of the
role which is client services and so
the goal here is to continue to evolve
our systems of record of our technology
systems
to make to make them interoperable where
we can
to work with the legislature to identify
ways in which
um the legislation may or may not be
impacting the ability to do that and
then
having that overall overarching
strategic plan of how we're going to get
there
additionally there's a lack of funding
and you'll hear this throughout all of
the different
all of our different bureaus is we have
deferred maintenance on
many of our systems and in some cases
due to the deferred maintenance it did
not mean that we weren't able to
we didn't have to provide the services
it meant that we had to go through
manual workarounds
either creating spreadsheets access
databases
or other smaller systems that are prone
to error
and can cause actual more work
in the long run and reduced reduced
services as a result
the continuous loop of lack of
technology to support our employee
employees
have has resulted in these manual
workarounds and
what what my goal is is to work with the
different teams across
the department as well as hand in hand
with department of information
technology
to identify those systems and provide
an operational as well as capital
approach to replacing those systems
over time in a strategic way
and then the final component is
information services team
not only in in my bureau
but also the ones embedded in different
areas of the organization
is is severely um
this severely under resourced so
on a rolling average we support 120
projects
we're only able to really get 30
projects done
each year so that leaves 90 projects
that don't get touched
year over year which results in
continuous workarounds and failures to
meet our citizen services
our goal would be to look at the
different areas within the department
and identify ways in which to expand
those information services teams and
when i say information services
business analysts that really drive
what what are the needs of the
organization how do we translate those
into technology solutions if there is
one
and really support business process
management
mr chair i believe you have a question i
do
i'd like to know uh if you're aware
of any industry benchmarks
that that you that would be relevant to
suggesting
what your appropriate staffing level
might be
so and i can't remember the exact
website but i was doing i
i've been listening to some of your
questions of of my peers
and there are different benchmarks that
we probably should research
more that would say for for project man
for project management it would be
anywhere from one to ten or one to
twenty projects four pm
depending on the size of the project so
if you have a very large project like
the mmis
or medicaid system you probably wanna
dedicate resources
to that so that they're not getting
distracted on other systems
so so let's let's just abbreviate it and
say that
let's talk in the future about external
benchmarks as
you as you learn more about it and get
and get some good
examples
and the other benchmarks that we were
looking at is how many technologies per
employee and so a lot of those are
usually at the like
the organization level so if we have ten
thousand or three thousand
three hundred right so i'd be concerned
about even
counting those right because how do
unless they have an additional job
identifier
that is an additional duty that they do
they would just
be buried in into the into the
weeds of each department so
um but all right i
i i feel your pain i've been here
so all right
we can keep going unless there are any
questions oh there's one
representative
thank you so you mentioned before
i'm surprised it doesn't show up on your
key challenges
um that you have been down 30
you're down 33 of your staff you're down
a third
that seems to me like a pretty big
challenge
and what i'm wondering is how long have
you been
down that many staff
and what
what do you think attributes to that is
that that you can't hire people in this
area
or that the wages are
out of sync with the private sector what
what attributes
to such a high term such a high rate of
vacancy certainly thank you for the
question representative walner and mr
chair
so you're right this third bucket here
of information services the resources
is a huge constraint and our 33 vacancy
rate
has resulted in from retirements so
we've had
two retirements in the project
management office
um and then we had a retirement as well
in the information services
and then we also had two people leave
the state to go to private sector
in and those and those people moved
on because they were able to double
their salaries as a result
so it was a very easy decision for them
to make where they're saying
we can do the same job or less work
and make more money so it is a challenge
we don't
government as a as a rule is not always
competitive with the private sector
however i would say being within
15 to 25 of the private sector would be
a good goal to attain
right now we're probably closer to 40 to
50 percent less than the private sector
which makes it
the pool of people that we're looking
for are either people that are
just getting into the field and need to
be trained
or they made their they made their
career in the private sector and now are
retiring to come to our organization
to support as a public servant so those
are our main
tools of resources that apply for
positions
and in in a lot of cases it's really
beneficial to get those people that have
30 40 years of experience
however it results in an attrition rate
at a much higher rate because they come
for a few years
and then they leave because they've
already retired from one career
and then they're coming here to try to
offer their services but they're not
here for a long term
so our goal when working with human
resources
is to address this attrition and this
this recruitment um opportunity
and we can't necessarily always impact
the
salaries of which we offer but we are
trying to
be more effective at our social media
presence as well as our recruitment
expertise
in terms of taking what we normally
would just post out there which is a
supplemental job description and making
it a little bit more enticing
of why you want to move to new hampshire
or why do you want to work for new
department of health and human services
do you have a follow-up representation
owner
had that many vacancies where your third
so the majority of the workforce
was full prior to the pandemic and then
as a result of the pandemic and the
hiring freeze we were
we had people retire and and move on to
other organizations
um that resulted in vacancies
in this specific area
okay i have if i could have one more
question
okay could you talk just for a minute i
did notice on
your budget pages that you do have
a very small amount of um funding for
overtime
and i'm wondering if you anticipate um
that you're
going to need to take a look at that
line
because um i i'm just wondering how
realistic is it
that you're going to be able to build up
that quickly in the next in the next
several months or even
year i mean i think it would take a long
time in this area to build up your
workforce
thank you for the question
representative wallner and mr chair
the the overtime budget
is primarily for a few key individuals
i would say the majority of the
positions
in the project management office are on
classified salary positions
as well as myself and two other
positions information
in the three other positions in the
information services area so
five positions in information services
and one
or two positions in gmo
would be subject to that overtime and
cobit 19 response funding for the
overtime because that's
generally where the overtime is being
hit and where we push
where where we're pushing overtime is
into the program areas or the
division areas where they have
information services teams
and they have larger overtime budgets to
to accommodate that
so that that was our general approach
but that
that key the key indicator that
is that we may have a difficulty
remaining in that overtime budget in the
thank you it seems like a big challenge
let's do a time check here miss mr
ripple after we complete this slide deck
and do the the
accounting um are we done for the day
you are yes all right very good thank
you
i'll try to i'll try to go faster no
i'm slowing you down i'm sure i i just
um i need to provide testimony at 2 15.
so
uh if i have to go then representative
irf can
so one of the questions was what would
we do
with the two with five percent increase
or five percent
decrease um the increase would
be reflected in about a two point two
million dollar increase
across the whole budget and the goal
there would be to improve our care
coordination in our
in our integrated eligibility
environment
and so our integrated eligibility
continues continues to evolve
we submitted a capital project that was
removed from
from the the governor's office
recommendation
that we still would need to be able to
expansions of that integrated
eligibility function
and that there's several different
components self-service
functionality to include ada
accommodations
as well as newer technology like chat
bots
where they can address questions quickly
and
numerous different enhancements to meet
our are
our service needs and the integrated
eligibility
additionally we would be looking to
improve our our care
our interoperability of systems and
expansion of our state's
systems like the closed loop referral so
that we could expand into hospitals and
then eventually into the managed care
organizations
so that we would have a closed loop
referral system which
allows for a citizen to go
to any any door and be able
to consent to release their information
if they so choose
to be shared with say they were showing
up at a
some sort of health related issue and
they needed food services
then they would be able to have that
information released
they would be consenting to that release
of information and immediately be
contacted by a food services
organization and
that would continue through if the food
services saw other needs and services
they would be able to be
part of that common network
if we saw a decrease that would have a
severe impact on our operational
capabilities to maintain our systems
because we are pretty lean
and the majority of our budget resides
in the class 27 transfers to the office
of
information technology and that 2.2
million dollar decrease would
impact our ability to support the
eligibility system
it would also defer maintenance we would
not be able to provide any
replacement for computers in the next
biennium
as well as that line line 27 transfers
to
oit is that what you're referring to
that that would take the biggest hit yes
mr chair it would we would have a choice
i guess essentially between
hitting that line or or laying off staff
yeah
and and so that oit that that's the doit
that is correct mr chair so this
class 27 is in in the information
services budget is where
all the transfers to infra department of
information technology occurs for the
department
and it's where where we pay for those
common services like email
file services and we have web services
but it also is where we pay for our
direct
costs including like eligibility systems
child support systems and general
maintenance on
everything that we do for an application
so am i right to believe that
that line has your deloitte money in it
and that
um from a contractual perspective mr
chair i'm not exactly how it gets paid
but yes
there are components of the class 27
budget that does have the deloitte
contract in it however we contract with
deloitte for more than just the
integrated eligibility system as you
heard earlier today
we also contract with them for our data
warehousing and data analytics
which is primarily not seeing a line
item that's big enough for any contract
so
i'm assuming that that's all your
contract transfers right there
that is that is correct mr chair but
there are some contract transfers that
are within the program area specifically
associated with grants
okay so uh earlier today you may have
heard
i uh suggested to ms telus
to follow up with you to talk about uh
eligibility the integrated eligibility i
had forgotten you were three years
downstream already
but um but you know it sounds to me like
like she could she could make dhhs some
money
if uh if she were able to streamline her
eligibility efforts
certainly and and she her team and and i
are
in constant conversation and so
that the is we we look at the third
party liability and fraud voice abuse as
part of the medicaid enterprise program
because it would be funded 90 by federal
funds
to support and we didn't tie it directly
to
integrated eligibility itself we we
currently have it in the
mmis contract and we'll be looking to
reprocure that solution
in the next biennium and and work in
conjunction with the enterprise business
intelligence platform
thank you uh representative wallner
you have a question your hands you do
i yeah i do um so
if i go to your
source of revenue again i see
the situation where the general fund
is going up and the federal funds are
going down
is that just
a formula that's being used that's
causing that to happen or is that
um is that really that there is a
difference
in what the federal what the feds are
going to um
support dave i can jump in there if you
want
that would be great so so while you're
jumping in i'm going to ask
representative irf to take over chairman
duties
and uh and if you guys are gone when i
come back
have a wonderful day thank you for
everything um
and so i'm gonna i'm gonna step away for
thank you are you are you ready
representative i am ready chairman mr
chairman
okay so what you'll notice in that
change from 1819 to 2021 is also the
total
amount of cost has decreased some and
that
is mostly due to us moving mmis
from the doit budget into the medicaid
budget so
those mmis is generally 90 10 sometimes
a little bit less
so the federal funds on that are the
reason that the federal funds are
decreasing there
they're over in the um medicaid budget
now
so i skipped over um this slide because
we pretty much already covered it from
uh
from a staffing perspective earlier in
the conversation
and then we just jumped into
this this slide showing our funding
changes over
year over year or by name over biennium
were there any other questions on
okay so then from uh
information services accounting unit
perspective we
i would turn it over to
mrs rounds support me and i will
certainly get involved when it comes to
all right if you want to stop screen
so we are on the last accounting unit
for the office of the commissioner which
is this one here in purple 5952
information services
that starts on 1181 and continues on to
11.82
the largest being the class 27 as we've
talked about
i'll ask you a generic question if
nobody else has one right now
i noticed that you there was a pretty
substantial increase in
that in the last in the well and current
year basically and yet there's still
another pretty good increase not as good
obviously
in this current year is that typical
growth
i mean the 15 i'm hoping is out of range
what is the four percent typical growth
from the you're talking about the
transfers to duit yeah i realized it's
probably more of a division one
question i thought maybe you would have
some insight since you obviously
fund a lot of it sure so i think and
i'll let dave jump in here too
the the largest thing here is is the
impact to covid
and i think there were a lot of things
that um didn't move forward
or ended up being funded with coveted
funds
um because of the nature that they ended
up being that's really making that
difference between
20 and 21 dave do you have anything you
want to add there
that's certainly the component and for
details the information department of
information technology implemented a
couple
very large platforms and along with us
which was the salesforce components
as well as the microsoft m365 which is
migrating us to the cloud
for email and file services as well as
our ability to
communicate with each other through a
teleworking environment
those are the primary so the shared
costs that
that department of information
technology
allocates to us increased primarily in
that
in that space our direct cost which is
where our maintenance and operations of
our existing application systems and our
computer hardware
actually went down um and so
as a relationship to those shared
services increases so that five percent
increase is mainly as rounds indicated
um related to coveted response but also
for a long-term perspective we need to
maintain those systems
so we needed to put the operating costs
in in place to
continue those services okay so i'm
really asking is do
you foresee that that growth has to
continue to maintain your services
so a representative earth that that
is not it's an annual cost to maintain
those services
um across those different systems until
such time that we would
we would turn them they would we would
retire those systems so they
when you when we moved to the platforms
uh cloud platforms there's
their software as a service platform so
they basically are
our annual costs now i understand the
annual cost like what i'm looking at
is the
there's a big jump we just talked about
15 in growth not not in
so in other words increased dollars and
it looks like in the first year
of this proposed budget you've got
another a little over four percent
growth and then it dropped in it drops
by half of that
i'm just asking if that if you're
anticipating that growth a growth rate
to continue
that's a good question representative
sorry i didn't understand the initial
question so the the growth rate
essentially would only continue based
off of mandates that we
we would receive so on a biennium basis
they do receive different mandates to
implement services
in the middle of of the uh the biennium
in in cases like center for disease
control and prevention might may
provide us a grant to implement a
service or a solution
that we're going to be required to
maintain and but they'll only give us
the one-time cost to start it up but not
the annual cost to
operate so i would anticipate that
growth
being anywhere from three to five
percent on a regular basis
i'm jay oh mom you didn't know can you
hear me
she's gonna hear you i think she's my
eyebrows
can you hear me yeah yes yeah go ahead
can you hear me yes yes
yes okay sorry about that
okay so in 2020
uh this isn't just about this can you
hear me now
yes can you hear us can't hear earth
we hear you earth okay
i can hear you okay
okay in 2020 you spent you had about 35
million
maybe it's your connection right
you're freezing up
we lost you mine
yeah in 2021 it went up
start over 40 million and that is
because of covet that's what i just said
okay
i texted her okay i think she's gonna
log back in
anybody else have any questions while
no if i can make some up
f um could you just okay i'm back then
is it any better
maybe she could relate a question
through you sharon
can you hear me yes
okay so let's try again
so you're up about you're up about five
million dollars from 20 to 21
uh additional five million
it's only gone we're doing so well
maybe it's a signal we should quit never
mind
[Music]
anything else you want to address karen
i don't think so
uh certainly if representative waldner
wants to email her question
through the lba have them add it to
their question list we'll make sure to
to get a response back um otherwise i
i don't think i have anything to add
if there are no other questions i would
just say thank you to all my ocom
directors and to beth kelly the finance
director for ocom and
and what are we doing tomorrow ken uh we
are working on the division of economic
and housing stability
the director for that area is chris
santaniello and the finance director for
that area is rebecca lorden
and i believe mike sent us those
handouts today
uh i think kevin did yes i mean kevin
i'm sorry usually you have those and
they're also on our website
too many names right
and i know that some people like to have
the powerpoint versions i
i will convert those um this afternoon
and get those over
oh he sent those as well i can actually
just okay that's fine
okay all right if you guys have them
we're good yeah
i'm all set okay super
well thank you all very much if there's